[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
all right
12-hour stream
i'm back
people what's going on
sunday the lord's day
i'm on fumes i ain't gonna lie i'm gonna
hold y'all
but i'm back
let's talk to everybody hustling
motivate what's going on how am i level
sounding they sound like 12 hours of
streaming
boozy decline was going on you know what
i'm saying what's the time time to drink
wine no doubt yeah yeah
i could use that sick slayer what's up
my mans what's going on gerald mack in
there early welcome lord silva you
already know cedric age william blank's
ship what's going on back from the dead
let's go to how y'all work out with
y'all ray man we got a lot of raid talk
to talk about
you know say lydia master
what's going on iop let's rock corey
mosley what up what's going on talk to
me
what's going on necromancer sale what's
up that was good thank you i appreciate
y'all
yeah it's been a long one
we gotta show fiona we still gotta come
through for the people
spoke to everybody
king pulling up
i don't know uh atticus here but if i
could mute it
back now you can do a mic check but
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
man you got his iop 10k shirt
all right you know
the man who got them horns high five i
got an array we we got to like the third
i think the counter or whatever it is
but we'll talk more in detail on that
plot than oj what's going on yo whatever
lord what's up you know del sol should
be back in the building
we're coming in hot today because like i
said two lords were doing a 12 hour
stream so
truth be told you're lucky to get a
shout-out
because i'm a hurtin
bad
i even gonna hold you but we gotta do it
for the people how to talk to the people
real quick
can you guys still hear me yeah yeah
yeah we did it
yeah what's going on guys man
if you if you feel energy coming out of
me today i'm gonna be road it's fake
this is manufactured energy speaking of
which shout out to advanced gg right now
i got my az my focus right now
i have to use that right now just to get
right
it's that type of
that type of question what's going on
y'all judah what's up
yeah it wouldn't have been as bad if i
didn't really sleep much tonight before
i lucked out because we go tough but i
lucked out i definitely got a d semi
decent rest before
that's what's probably saving me but
there was a strong chance to shoot it
without going to t i want this but this
would have been the con call out day
like yo
anyway look
we're going to close it up
get some dallas bars king is pulling up
saul pulling up the original ilp
in its form doing it back no guess
because we got we got to get back to the
core the essence of this you know what
i'm saying so we try to do once a month
no guessing i was actually happy there
was no guess i didn't have to do it
anyway see y'all in a minute
oh i hold a fix down
he said i was concerned yeah you fixed
that i was concerned about what third
yeah it trusts me when i tell y'all
trust me when i tell you it was
it came close to you don't stay out of
bed like you're adding
i'm dead i'm gonna stay in that bed
without a llama
[ __ ] about getting the extra yes yes i
got the extra i gotta check on my
shipping i gotta check on my ship and it
should be soon cause you got your oh man
i'm jelly i gotta check out my [ __ ] but
yo we will be back king will be pulling
up
see y'all in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't wanna be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we were
messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog's thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that
this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
you i ain't here to boy you you ain't
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you i
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
hear you
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
if i can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it nothing it's
cool and it's beautiful we let you know
that your dreams are pursuable whatever
you want to do then it's doable if you
got work on a sunday it's suitable cause
you can listen to this in your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right back today and the bikes are
hot and let's check the levels real
quick because i'm very unprofessional
today excuse me excuse me here you hear
ye your excuse sir
and i think we are live i think just
checked the levels because they're very
unprofessional today very professional
are we good we can use me track below
yeah just i mean not the levels i mean
check the stream check the stream just
real quick but anyway um
12 hours later on the stream we're here
we're live we're live here using life
thank god we put that rule back where we
don't have a guess for what one show
above and it worked out great but anyway
welcome back to the iron lord podcast
llc and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 247 it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day
and today we've got the 12-hour vow of
disciple raid race to discuss
elden rings the fiasco that kind of was
nothing to do with us
oh yeah we got stuff to talk about for
sure eldon rings massive success halo
infinite season 2 update and gran
turismo impressions to discuss so we're
going to get right into it so let's
introduce the four horsemen of gaming
the original knights of the realm here
at the round table my co-host with the
co-most my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man lord addict of the attic show and
my 12 hour raid partner how are we doing
i'm exhausted remember what's funny is
like
because uh right now my mom's in town so
she was in there and i and i told her i
was like wake me up at 12 30. she's like
i think it is 12 there's like no it's
time
yeah
literally i went to bed
like it wasn't even five minutes after
that because i was i was already
exhausted three hours before that like
that's why
people kept saying this is the last try
and i had to just speak up that last
time this is the last try
we probably went for an hour on the last
tries in quotes
it was it was a lot a lot of last tries
going on but we're going to get into
that
you know your beanies inside out addict
right
he's right
[Music]
other than that sir uh dave you got a
chance to play anything else
um
a lot of eldering
and i started a triangle strategy oh so
i be looking out for a review for that
in probably the next
three or four days because i don't have
to know like that to finish that so but
that game's not eldering it's not gonna
take me a hundred plus hours to beat it
so no doubt no doubt and of course we
have our most technical gaming lord the
solo gamer who lives for the
single-player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus the lord of
clarity and lord patron of the iron bank
my man freshly rested off of batman
which i didn't attend lord sovereign how
are you doing
i am doing well doing fantastic first
off apologies for missing last week uh
yeah i miss gustav and luca and jimmy
champagne but i was listening live so i
was
laughing
um what did i do so i finally beat the
halo infinite campaign i did that okay
finally beat that um
it's fine oh
gameplay-wise is fantastic right but
they left it where obviously there's
more to come
certain revelations about you know
characters and stuff like that that
happened um i like the
sort of conclusion of the uh
of certain storylines and
i like that but i it wasn't like it's
what a kind of what i feared with an
open world halo okay i didn't feel the
set piece moments were there like in a
halo 3 and i i didn't feel those moments
were there but the gameplay moment to
moment is great man sorry for that
that's why i always felt like
the perfect type of pacing i would love
for my halo
is the pacing and set pieces i see from
wolfenstein
yeah oh yeah where you it's just all
interactive that that's how the campaign
i would personally why like a a set
piece narrative
linear story like crazy
though
see that's the thing you got to find the
middle ground right yeah this is a lego
game i like the the the
i like the the open world of halo but i
did feel like and i even said in my
review that i didn't feel like as alive
as it was it still at the same time did
not feel alive like it kind of felt like
a deadline
there wasn't a lot of like that you
didn't even see like a lot of like
animals and stuff in the open world
it really wasn't because they were
killing the animals and
the story about it is is dope i just
like when you find pockets of people and
things going on in that little pocket
like what are you talking
how many times did you drop a ship on or
a tank onto one of them
and i'm like yo
could you move from
i guess what i meant by like
the world being alive is at the
beginning it makes sense you're you're
you're coming into a war that you lost
all the regions have been
they've been taken over by the bandage
but i felt like the more banished you
took over i felt like the more presence
you should have seen the marines like
not just a couple here and there like by
the end of that game half that ring if
you would have done those side quests
and stuff should have been occupied by
the marines
yeah
so i did that um i didn't get the chance
to play any more horizon this weekend
and then just last night i got to play a
little bit more of eldon ring
i got i got it
she made a good choice
and batman i have to say
it
it is it is a different batman movie and
i was there for it um
there were moments when i watching it if
i was like okay this is a graphic novel
and they're going all in on the graphic
novel and to that extent it was very
much a batman detective
story
there were moments there
that i think because of it's a movie and
it's like a three-hour movie that could
have interspersed a little more action
up front okay because i think towards
the end of the movie you got more which
maybe some people expect from a batman
or superhero movie right right um and
maybe they intersperse that more but i
tell you this i
i just like that it's a different batman
movie
i don't know that it's going to be for
everybody because some people are going
to go in there looking for the next dark
night the next to be honest with you
there are people racing i haven't seen
no one i haven't seen not really one
negative review i heard um you know very
good things but i thought it was going
to be like batman year one when you're
talking about being a detective when
he's learning his craft he's daniel
craig right before you know like james
bond uh moment happened when he gets
refined so how we all fell in love with
daniel craig for being a rough bond the
rough bond yeah this is him this is that
yeah yeah this is this is him
but it's that
coupled with the fact that mentally
he's not where he needs to be to be to
to be what we know to be batman he's not
here yet he's still he's you know what's
funny
yeah
i was watching
a like a documentary of them making that
yeah and the dude who played batman
robert something i can't remember his
name
he actually like is as far as like what
batman looks like and how they portray
batman that's entirely him because he
refused to do stuff that previous
batman's did like shape up get buff like
yeah it's him like
because they said they wanted to put a
bodysuit on him and he said no like yeah
in terms of he said you can easily play
batman the way i look now you don't have
to do all this extra stuff
and it comes off it comes off more like
yeah he's he's a little people are
sitting there saying i mean that's a bad
narrative of him because it seems like
he's a malcontent um
yeah because they ain't directing them
wanting him don't work out
the superhero shape yeah you don't
understand like how
the dude that plays uh captain america
um
right uh chris evans yeah chris evans
got into superhero shape you can see his
difference between the human torch and
and captain america you can clearly see
the difference in his body
he didn't want to become ben affleck's
version of batman so you know but he did
work out he got into swimmer shape
and let's be honest like the the bar is
set so hard high with so many different
people that i respect that in a way it's
like yo i'm not trying to do with them
dudes i'm gonna bring my flavor to it i
was supposed to act this out and it's
totally different like if you like if
you read graphic novels there's a lot
there's a lot of uh
the
long halloween
there is
the long halloween there's hush there is
a no man's land there's a little bits
and pieces of all of that you heard um
and they do it like
it's one of those things but it's kind
of like joker i love joker i never
wanted to see it again because it's so
disturbing
this i want to see again just because i
really want to get the sense of like
okay where does this batman stand oh
it's like the pantheon
but um but it is it is it is an
oppressive move
when you watch it it's like damn man
this this place is bleak
shout out shout out to e15 manga got a
shout out on twitch users uh uh he's a
great batman too can't wait to see him
in a sequel beat to be bruce so i just
want to shout out
what i enjoy
is someone that was that was deemed that
one character he's always been that
twilight dude
that finally came out and got something
else like that because you don't see
that often like i was talking a couple
months ago and it's like the dude played
harry potter like you don't see me
playing really anything his range is
crazy though
harry potter is crazy like but i
remember right after harry potter he did
a play on broadway called equus and he
was what naked like button
is the fact that but see i like twilight
though
and you're not going to think about it
you're not going to get a lot of dudes
that admit that though i thought he
didn't hang on twilight though i just
couldn't stand the girl she had no range
her face yeah expression and everything
and that's the thing for whatever reason
she's a great actress too that's like
you see her now and it's like okay no
she's no she's good she's good i don't
know i'm not even lie
everything she's been in for me has been
hot garbage like
just now
anything is
in pattinson like have you seen his
other stuff like i was talking about
shout out to lord meds we were talking
about this yesterday i was like yo
pattinson if you see look watch a movie
called the lighthouse yeah um with
william to fall with him
wow
yo you know what yeah
what's nice though is
when he was first cast everyone doubted
it
to kaibatsu and medes and
marlodious laura's barlows which i did
out of 10.
but i'm glad y'all had a good time
i was like i gave you the courtesy text
at five o'clock i was like you ain't
going nowhere yeah you know you knew it
you knew it i gave you what i was like
it's gonna be a game time decision yeah
yeah
and that's the thing i wasn't sure if
you know you know mez i was gonna make
it at that point because of that yeah
and then you know he rolled in on his
unicycle
selected a whole video
oh no
[Music]
but i definitely i definitely want to do
a roundtable review of this with you
guys
i'll probably say it next week yeah
probably next week that's what i'm doing
at this point that after that raid
everything this weekend's done yes
back to normal life anyway that's what
it's all
yes sir and of course waiting patiently
and also
arrested
the incredible hulk of this aka the
access game
the profit of xbox kwami
king of the statues who defends nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
be love it lord king how are we doing
sir i'm doing
[Laughter]
you'll be making fun of us for that 12
hours but you'll be the first person to
be like let's see who's like 12 days of
experience
he's going to be like you i want the
premium carry after that yeah
so
did someone beat it yesterday yeah
[Laughter]
actually we had
it is not really a jumping puzzle bro oh
wow timeline is crazy with you wildcats
oh chocolate tito yesterday shout out to
the zone for putting on chocolate tito
versus uh martinez yesterday they
thought the young bulls gonna come in
and school oh boy chocolatito came out
looking like a young muhammad ali his
name is chuck chili tito
no
gonzales chocolate roman
1950 gloves his gloves is the color you
know like muhammad ali used to come out
there with the caramel gloves yeah the
brown and
i'ma tell you
he put he took this boy to school
and just when you thought that gares was
off like okay uh he already learned him
the 10th frown came and this dude had a
second gear in his butt
pulse and he turned it up he was doing
things to this boy i was like oh god
stop the fight
it's just an exaggeration it just says
you ain't got to do it like that
he was placing his shots he was he had
an educated jab
yo
this
dude
it was like
the young boy because he was talking
about you know he might lose this one
because the young boy is coming in and
he has the figure in the string
chocolatito chocolatito's on his last
leg here and we don't know what he's
going to do next chocolatito came in and
said i heard everything you said oh
y'all must have forgot
with the old school roy boy
pound for pound oh performance okay okay
like because young boy is good if you
look at him you know he's gonna look
like a bump
um this week
i've been playing mad destiny
um shout out to my man hot monkeys love
him for getting the dlc oh hey guys
yeah we still on
30 days of coats right now i'm looking
like
what am i what am i looking like bane am
i looking like the vulture i don't know
what
[Laughter]
like a rested
[Laughter]
but he was looking at that right and be
like man
he was good he had that he had the band
going he was like oh you think shabba
shabbat
you cannot do that
[Laughter]
i don't
anyway what else you've been playing sir
oh my god everything like that
i sat there and watched y'all buckled
down for 12 hours
and i was watching y'all and my wife i
said they still going don't sell
batteries energizers they're out here
they still go she said that's 12 hours i
said look at the time babe look
i'm having my drinks i'm toasting to
y'all
yo sister put a raised fraud on you in
the chat you put brave fraud
alert i can tell you use a day one night
and finisher
this my friend is you hold up hello
we're sinister watching other people's
streams again what are they doing listen
you know it's that moment we're gonna
get into it's always that moment yeah
that's why i laugh because i'm just like
look i'll be here for the experience but
we will get into it it's so funny
so all right so i've been playing like
everything
um
i was uh
this game called
far
dropped and i was waiting for that game
to drop for a minute so and it's like
you got aquaman's baby
you don't ever need to come up for air
under the water like so you get to swim
and it's it's a minor puzzle game um
and it moves from uh from left to right
and you gotta solve little things it is
no worse nobody's talking so far from
what i'm what's what's happening
but
you control a ship
and you're in charge of maintenance
you're in charge of it's it's it's it's
very different right so it was a very
different change of pace from what i was
playing like fortnite um you know
destiny getting monkey up to speed
helping him through the story he doing
it i would talk to him
i told him a quick build yeah on his uh
his void uh walker um
what you call it uh
you use devour a lot we use devourer
yeah yo bro yeah if i was crazy
saves you bro yeah in the raid i will
say this like there was a lot of moments
devour for void 3.0 just really could
control it's weird you could really
control it yeah they really worked at
first i was pissed off with it because i
was thrown into it i didn't know what
was going on yeah and i said i guess i'm
not using void but after i got that
build down pack uh shout out to um
uh who helped me
uh do that uh
i'll check again um anyway so i got the
build together showed monkey the whole
build and the monkey's up to speed with
it and then
i decided to
pop in my elder ring oh
um first i got to say a lot of you
people that was talking about there's
not a robust
uh
character creation
y'all just talking about hair yeah okay
okay no just talking about it that's
fair there may be some minor that's fair
but you're all right females is lit
you're lit
boy made me yeah you
yeah and this is when you only care
about yourself
[Laughter]
i've never cared about how i look in
these games like i didn't realize i was
an
exo in destiny until like a week ago
like i took off my mask like i'm i'm an
exo like what like
i'm a robot i'm not even a human so why
would i care what i look like in any
other game like like especially in like
the front software games i'm putting
armor on i ain't never going to see that
like continue
mostly
but at the same time again the sliders
and the stuff that you're able to do you
can do the width of the nose the
dimensions in the eyes the round and of
that very robust very robust in a lot of
things and again i just i don't see
where you know
talk about a hard
game pause
for
people that aren't ready for that style
right yeah because i'm looking at the
blood and on the floor and i'm like oh
okay i can read the blood i said hi
blood
and then you see some dude like
no
and at first saw you was like you were
scared you were getting attacked the
first time you saw it exactly i was like
what's up because addicts said the red
people right so i'm like red people oh
ripping oh no i said oh no he's he's a
admiration he's he's warning me of
something and these dudes is trolls they
tell you oh secret over here ain't no
damn secret over there so
i'm like okay i go down and i look at
the world
shout out to them needing to refine that
stuttering please i got v i got vrr on i
got all this stuff working and
and it's on priority frame rate
oh oh oh wait wait wait wait wait that
how
looks good like it runs good from what i
saw with demon souls and attic playing
demon souls runs good yeah it plays well
no none of them did at launch though
second row was broken on xbox okay yeah
yeah i got it later yeah but again
i mean i'm like okay i'm i'm gonna try
to work this out lock the camera on
whoever i'm fighting yeah
i go and the dude says i see one blood
stain right and i see these crips all
across
and i'm like in the one dude
you see him getting beat down
i said what the hell
and nobody none of the blood stains said
look out none of them
i walk forward the bosses that how you
gonna have the boss
like i don't have no hit points i don't
have anything like i'm just old king
walking in the streets trying to fight
birds to level up not gonna happen here
the boss jumps out beats the brakes off
me real quick one swipe get out of here
well you talk about the crab looking
thing yeah
and so the biggest question is how many
times have you died in the game
oh i got a lot
i mean i died a lot like i died i died i
died like you know people change socks
like i die like that like i died of
stuff that you you see like i'm gonna
kill you he's like not today brother
all
right
what's it gonna take for you to stream
this game nothing like who you want to
see me be disrespected
yes
i was listening to last week's show and
when you were like i need elder ring i'm
like
the the bank was protesting last night
i'm not giving you elderly you cannot
play this game no but no see i want to
play it but i don't want to play it to
broadcast it today you got to put
yourself out to the world
he said do i need to do a patreon
will be here
big will be outside
oh will me um my bad i didn't get back
to you uh next wednesday okay um all
right so
so what what would it take for you to
stream that game
okay you got one two and i know they're
not gonna do it
hey
they gotta i'll stream
oh oh okay this works perfect
we just put up the road of uh road to
pax uh shirts inside uh with teespring
yes right
every week we hit
10
uh roll to packs items all right i'm
gonna put them up right now i'll stream
all right
every our
i was streaming for two hours i was
streaming two hours
two hours yeah i heard that yeah i
better get them shirts
you better get them shirts i just put
the links in there if y'all hold up to
his work they say king alter counts are
all the twos
he said king's all the guys there's only
like two twos like it's been like so
many
it sucks it sucks that i got only two
friends and i love y'all
[Laughter]
you know what you know what i i got you
man too
thank you
the world wants to see this yo misty
said cake so boujee won't stream for
free
this man knows how to work the audience
flame says friends yo they stupid
i'm i'ma sit here and eat pineapples and
see y'all not getting the tan
in the background y'all know what to do
we know how we do with 10k shirts so
that was not
[Laughter]
don't feel bad
why so i could play the ps4 version oh
that was probably what you should do
yeah
and of course
no
is that it kim
that's all it's going to be because
anytime i say i'm playing anything
they're gonna make me play it for bucks
and of course we have the gaming ninja
super
super tired the [ __ ] don't feel like you
know spreading the realness in the realm
of the iop i'll tell you what you want
to hear what you need to hear salute
to my main mystery plays we just did a
defining duke it was lit um talking
about what's going on with obsidian
looks like there's more information that
came out addict right about that so
go go check that out that's up live on
um what's called last media youtube
channel check that out but yo but if you
can if you're part of the patreon we got
a banger mark dara from bioware classic
interview he's giving up the t
he no putting no punches on everything
dragon's age mass effect um anthem we
went there he had no problems going
there so
please if you're not a part of the last
10 minute apprenticeship this is the one
to get a part of because it was premium
premium bars and we learned a lot about
game development we learned a lot about
ea's relationship and how the
misconceptions that a lot of gamers have
also about pre-order like he was
spitting spitting so yeah yeah not okay
i i gotta i gotta do one thing you gotta
go for it blaze 4k oh yeah blade yeah
wait before you go blaze i ain't got
nothing to do with that so why are you
throwing him
yeah like
like i shot somebody too but i'm like yo
i'm over here civilian i'm like
i could just i could just see it i could
just see it now like they they remember
that that scene uh uh boys in the hood
where the dude shot the dude
like you're the one that's shooting
driving
[Music]
i know you guys do that someone make
that a clip
anyway blaze 4k i thought sony was going
to uh uh
mr date
um i didn't know it was far more
sinister
than this but we'll get into that on my
topic
ben the knee
is in and i'm bending me
to my man blaze 4k here you go
down on that knee absolutely absolutely
that's real that's real see king king is
a man about it not just sit through the
rest of the podcast it's messed up
he's so big he don't look like he did
nothing that you don't really get enough
of that kingdom
oh they're already being bought
we heard that about 10k shirts and look
what happened but anyway that was
something totally different that was
that's that was the apparition get those
aberrations
anyway so you're salute that i thank you
for addressing that so we got that yeah
check out the blaze you're not getting
it
again
go back to the screen
look at it and i told you i would do it
on the show so this is the first show
back
you got it
so yeah man oh we had dad so check that
out check out old last word was lit the
homies thai guy yo we had chris ray gun
pull up
destiny talk or the last word talking
witchcreen everything yo it was fire and
um yeah man so i was gonna do that or
actually solve you want to get the super
chats and then i gotta set some things
up man oh and and and then plus chris
raygun
let's bring you on the road man let's go
oh yeah i got no no i told him no no i
told him he's doing a world tour like we
doing that the world yeah they ain't
coming out people know we already got
through you know what i'm saying we
already got through so yeah come check
that out but y'all stop get this super
chat
let me copy and paste this last one so i
have it there
so last one i got a suicide king unless
and you know mm-hmm in case anything
pops off on your name
so
we have to start off we got gerald mack
member for one year upgrading to lord
silva thank you sir
gerald mack always repping the lords
sir then we have sith lord 5 super chat
looking forward to march 17th king king
and boom one on one xb log live sorry
continue oh you knew that was coming
this is fantastic
thank you for everyone's hard work on
every show you guys make look at you
acting like he's got hope you done king
yeah he don't know he only though
i find you know why because they're
gonna get into these topics
[Laughter]
after 120 hours i beat eldon ring and
wow from soft knocked this out of the
park i'm really happy more people are
enjoying it game of the year have a
great show he said a hundred and what
he's number three
what
100 i got i got i think 110. oh
you about to have like 20 if we do this
two hour thing a week
mm-hmm
oh they telling me to check twitter what
they do oh no what has happened yeah
they got me and you know ricky
[Music]
i don't know what they did they just
telling me to check twitter i don't know
why but we're going to see them continue
soccer
that we have donal taco ten dollars of a
chat juggling triangle strategy and
elden ring right now both games are
amazing i said elden ring was an 8.5
last week but it's a 10 not gonna lie
still not better than breath of the wild
but it's pushing the more i play
i got some thoughts on that too that i'm
talking about i definitely do
then we have christopher jones with the
four pound 49 pence uh super chat
welcome lord to this glorious sunday saw
the batman yesterday and i confidently
believe it's one of the best comic book
adaptations of all time wow good movie
good movie good morning
then we have kushik talukdar all right
20 pounds super chat welcome back saab
last week attic butchered my name so far
how are you gonna someone tried to
complain about how his name was put out
my friends were watching and they
couldn't stop laughing i used to be at
the top of my class at real style of
d101 feel like i'm banished to the
shadow room look man i think i think we
could agree get about it i i think we
can all agree you knew that was
happening
that's super cheap you knew that was
happening man
look it's kind of the beauty of
addiction
when you super chat again then i'm
reading it look in the mirror
with his name
he could have made
we could clearly tell that i was at the
top of my class
it is what it is
i hope i did it justice if not correct
me out and i'll take care of it
we have splendiferous five dollars
no you wasn't here last week but this
one for you lord saw jesus oh here we go
i i remember how you was talking about
my spelling on that stupid joke but i'm
saying you like the style though no no
no reading is riff reading is
fundamental let's go solve is very
particular about spelling with those
super chats y'all better be right man
you guys never heard all audible what's
that what's that website that reads
that's the way to go audible
man
yeah
over here sitting here acting like we
read in 2022 man audible is a thing
game i'm already complaining
no that's true i've already i haven't
read this one in a long time continue
let me play with your joystick yo
oh
mom
i see my man is back with the fresh cut
hey
yo
who who is this you got a secret
environment let
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last night reminded me of why i love you
guys 30 plus hours with the lord just
amazing even when sinister almost sick
addicts have oh my
[Music]
i don't know but i think you're already
done i swear yeah that's like five ten
pop up already
continues uh you will forget then we got
that we got
we got uh
random blade two pounds of chattanooga
oh how about king i got an okay mage all
right so you have other partners
that's right
then we got played five dollar super
chat man 12 hours in that raid i only
got one question are y'all winning
guardians
thank god i avoided that and played
triangle strategy instead game of the
year no i care about you when you're
striving
shut up
shut up
you know what's funny today
but i'm taking all this crap in the
bumps away i'm taking him
go remove him
[Laughter]
i will say you guys thought that 12
hours it was pretty bad you know how bad
it was that we had to go back in at six
today
he got raiden played a good 2000 did you
see the uh uh horizon forbidden west dev
mad at elden ringo i didn't see that i
didn't see that yeah i heard about it i
heard about it he should be upset that
you know we should you know yeah that's
all i'll say should be a
sense for sony for not pushing that game
back or at least trying to come up with
your thoughts
it's literally that meme of the big
giant colossal giant looking over like a
little cupid
elden ring
forbidden west
about that is they are the metroid of
sony he's stupid you're ridiculous
you're hot but you eat outside
continue big big miyazaki out in the
streets
at this point eldon ring is like
like a five-star restaurant and
forbidden west is like a mcdonald's
there you go
get that crunchwrap supreme
continue sorry suicide kings two dollars
super chat there will be no helping king
i will enjoy this
somebody wants to help you okay suicide
i'm gonna remove you from my friends me
all right we got raiden blade again two
power super chat i'm listening but
playing elden ring yeah most people are
i i can imagine
then we got har gate city once again 10
super chat ps5 players say wait a minute
10 super chat i don't know if this is
targeting genie but we'll see
ps5 players say play ps4 version of
eldon ring on ps5 because they hooked up
to that tcl tv can't afford the god led
with vr oh wait ps5 still doesn't have
vr wow
but they do have a version for you
you have a verse ridiculous
keep it going all right then we have
raider blade again two power super chat
84 hours in elder ring it has my soul
new shang sung yeah my people
they put the crest in the chat for the
newest member of the realm amblix shout
out to you sir thank you shout out to
you
then we got suicide kings member for 17
months saab welcome back thank you sir
no more sundays off for you find the new
job addict just wasn't ready
the butchering
yeah
i definitely wasn't ready
i feel like when i'm reading super chats
you guys go extra just to make me read
more right
it's funny though
one of these member messages is kind of
crazy
i just i live from when you have to read
an inappropriate title that's what i
want yeah it's kind of funny
then we have flame two dollars with that
can take my scribe but you can't take my
freedom okay
you're on probation mrlordsongaming.net
you're on probation until further notice
you've been silenced
[Laughter]
there we go
freedom
there we are this one's funny this one's
funny then we got tony breitbart for 20
months my sister-in-law looking at the
tv drooling while sob reading super
chats got me dying she just said i don't
know if he's addy or poppy i'm dying
yo but we doing that uh some segment man
we gotta we gotta start
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you know once certain things start
getting heard in the background all of a
sudden the door opens up
what's going on
continue continue
there we have otaku oh member for 10
months thank you sir i'm in church right
now listening to the lord the son of my
lord and savior man
not listen to us in church you better
not see you you got the ear buds
the preachers saying hallelujah hell
yeah yeah they said solve me to make
holy fans i'm done continuing
saul's only fans is is just his face on
camera
asmr we're gonna have we're gonna have
doing mukbang i'm done wow
that's funny
of course um there we go iron mike five
dollar super chat breath of the wild and
ellen ring must be singing that r kelly
and us the same girl because they both
knocked down that a chick wow wow
that is a very king eska analogy there
tag team back again there we go hard to
find two dollar super chats top only
fans win all right let's start there it
is
we all caught
we're caught up all right let me get the
merch thank god let me get the merch
um
shout out you know what i'm saying we're
bringing that back up don't we got
topics
oh you got tony bryant we got tony brown
where's merch yeah we got tony bryant on
some chat 12 hours in the raid you guys
are nuts contest mode got extended so me
and some of the iop clan brothers going
in blind tomorrow night absolutely we
did have like three iop clan yeah
no doubt no doubt wow
what plan difference two dollars in that
that head gonna get rubbed today lord
sob not by me
[Laughter]
anyway paul that was super pause whoa
oh shout out to stuff shawn about the
classic t he says salute this is why my
lord
no no this is oh no this is old it's all
good anybody who said something that
when we off i try to read it
salute to the lord from the elded ring
of ireland he said thank you for the
business every week shout out to the
best team new york bill i just want to
make sure we didn't miss anything all
right anonymous
what i do want to say is if you actually
get out to uh to to pax east and you got
on that shirt take a picture with me
yeah take a picture with us all right
we'll be out there april oh t-shirt all
right back from dead iop clan member oh
gee salute he got the classic t he said
just what are you doing he said you
you should have just lied to him i
should have just lied at this point yeah
he said he got done he said i just want
to show my support to my destiny
brothers got to look good when i see you
at gcs oh you go to gcx in june yeah
well i'll be there for sure i mean
addict should be there you know what i'm
saying i'll see what's going on with
king and schedule um back for deadpool
and he bought a dab cap uh oh dad cat
for sale just wanted to show my support
to my destiny brothers gotta look good
when i see you john that's what's up
necromancer oh here they come
necromancer zell got that classic pax t
in red this is for the king gaming
stream
mystery got us packed stainless tumbler
20 ounce for all the runes king loses in
the stream
[Laughter]
yeah you guys got the joy that zgl7
bought the classic t packs in white he
said
that's all he said
then we got the oldest silver tac uh pax
bar little tumbler joint you know what
i'm saying bearded panda gotta appear to
uh uh packs the premium team ain't
nobody gonna forget one king so he got
that so that's it for right now
yeah betty pan is up in there so look we
got all the merch all that good stuff
let's let's focus okay first of all
public service announcement let's just
focus on the topics
you know nothing like that
get off the rails king you let's not get
crazy so look y'all it's that time
of the month lords of gaming.net we have
been blessed to have tremendous writing
talent all those who aspire to be great
in lieu of my brother lord dizzy will
i'll give some words on after but um yo
the competition is extremely fast man
tremendous team we got new people
signing up all the time being a part of
this the meetings be lit you know what
i'm saying and uh just a lot of
collaborative shootouts again i want to
salute before i even do the whole scribe
in the birthday salute to the editorial
team man everyone's really pitching in
shout out to the lord magmal shout out
to dick shout out to lord frost i see
you still in the background you ain't go
away
salute to you man you're always giving
your input and everybody macho gondor's
condor's back salute to everybody in the
team man really making it right it's
good but it's time
to celebrate one particular lord who's
recently bending the knee that means the
knees is out oh
we wanted to bend the knee to the
editorial team and everybody
that's what that was that was on the fly
just freestyle there anyway um
anyway for a mistake but look here's the
time we got to celebrate one that
definitely went above and beyond in the
month of february exceptional writing he
had a tremendous uh seafood coverage i
was loving that seafood coverage you
know what i'm saying he had all oh saul
he had a interview with the developer
kung fu kicking all our people jonah
yeah from welfare games he did that and
he is the lord of elder ring and from
software games covering smile because he
knows really no it's real my man we
probably present the lord dizzy lognet
scribe of the month lord infinite ammo
aka daniel omoroso
how we doing people
speak thank you very much thank you cog
thanks guys
it's a real pleasure real pleasure no
doubt man i feel kind of i've got to be
honest i feel a little guilty because
since i found out i was writer of the
month i've kind of down tools and i
haven't really
got to blame elder ring right riding on
the coattails of your success
i've got to blame elder ring i'm 75 if i
was in there and i'm on i'm actually on
the last boss but i've tried to mop up
as much of the side stuff as i possibly
could as well so i've got a lot of
writing to do about that so i will catch
up i've been slacking but i'll catch
that up i promise
honestly it's a pleasure i love being
part of the team love love adding as
much input as i can it's a real pleasure
brother it's been awesome to have you in
such a short time you know again you've
been contributing i love the approach to
go get an attitude shout out to flame
everybody's giving me your props couple
of scribes in there congratulations you
don't say that's what's up man he's been
killing it and like i said futurist
brian can't wait to be doing more things
with you get ready for uh april it's
gonna be busy for you
[Laughter]
we got stuff going on in fact coverage
should be coming your way but now all
jokes are
tremendous work brother and salute to
you really appreciate you since you
joined the team and i had to give you
your roses make sure you are square up
with solving the iron bacon get some get
some of that sweet
thing
i'll be in touch so don't worry
appreciate you thank you guys i really
appreciate it honestly thank you so much
no doubt enjoy your sunday buddy thank
you for taking the time
no problem at all you take care no doubt
uh cog i actually managed to get this
going the patreon all right so yeah
while you do it while we do that um let
me just get finished my thing i just
want to
you know i know we got
a little dizzy scribe in a month and you
know we definitely want to give our
respect to that but yo it's been a year
man it's many years
anniversary we lost our brother and um
you know i just wanted to still shout
out the family you know what i'm saying
and and and rose and the sun and you
know we definitely want to honor you and
keep your legacy going he meant so much
to us and it just really hit me like
damn it's been a year man you know what
i'm saying
so yeah it's a little damn i i see you
know wifey's posts and sometimes it hits
me so i try to give her space because
you don't want to all the time be up on
someone but i definitely want to send
love to the family all the um the the
all band the whole team you know what
i'm saying reaper
frodo chris
his mom everybody man we still kind of
stay in touch and i'm probably not as
close as i should that's why i want to
say it publicly you know what i'm saying
just to let you know that yo never
forgotten always going to keep his
memory alive and um yeah this is this is
for him so salute to him put a uh lord
dizzy put something in the chat you know
what i'm saying throw it out for him one
year man since we lost our bro and uh
definitely missed him i don't know if
anyone else wants he he'd be proud man
you'll be real proud of what
everything's happening he'd be super
proud yeah no doubt no doubt that's all
i got but uh let's get these uh patreon
in the business right
no doubt let's get into this once again
it's that time of the month to say thank
you to all our patreon members and
youtube members um and give back to you
guys
a tear or something in there that a
patreon member can come in and help me
find to find that let me get a patreon
dude to get in there with this ring
because y'all want to be the ones in the
chat
for ten thousand dollars a patreon
white wallet
and wipe out all the number ones
all right so let's go we have let's get
our 10
gift card giveaway
and that goes to
[Music]
joe bell
government
[Music]
all right
our 20 gift card super i keep saying
super challenge our 20 gift card
giveaway goes to
[Music]
brendan carr raris
tortoise
that's his name brendan that's his name
brendan carr rarest the rarest of
tortoises
[Laughter]
salute salute
no doubt no doubt
all right and our teespring giveaway for
the month of march goes to
get the trip
well okay i'll read it
dustin furman
what
he's got he has his tentacles in a in
iop you know how he does
he's like 10 cent he's a 10 cent oh
yeah he's got that 10 ownership
[Laughter]
what the hell financed that
all right
yeah so we're good thank you once again
to all our patrons and youtube
subscribers we appreciate all the help
and the support it is
absolutely 100 percent appreciated all
right cool and i just got one last bit
of business and then we gotta show the
kind and get into
so um yeah man we got i believe the uh
poll yes last week results are in the
people have spoken pertaining to review
scores for highly anticipated games how
much should bugs glitches or major
performances influenced the final score
the winner of the three-way poll at only
four that only 49 of the vote was a
studio's past pedigree should not
influence the review if riddled with
bugs or major performance issues group
coming in travis agrees coming in at
second place at 32 was the messi lloyds
y'all just mad they reviewed your
favorite game with a lower metacritic
than the ops and in last place
with 18 of the vote was if the game play
fun factor and our master class in a
genre then bugs should not [ __ ] the
score group shout out to all the lords
who participate in the poor little
addict what do you think do the people
did the people get it right they said
that [ __ ] mad about your pedigree
look man
after last night's rain you guys got
this you won you won
so look we're gonna get right into it um
you know it seems like i got to i
brought the campfire with me right now i
got the campfire with me
we're intermingling
we're crashing the party is what i like
to say it's a mixer
this is are we in high
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was very creepy that was very extra
that was a pause worthy
yeah okay
that's when you go back to the work desk
and hr be called yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the issue
did he speak to you inappropriately
who gave you boxes the coffee cake
but look man i appreciate it we've got
the last word podcast in the realm
the triumvir is here let's start with
the cheetah first
ray day
what up what's going on man involved the
disciple let's talk about it the highs
the lows everything that went back like
give me your vibe man what what was it
like cause you had the all-star team man
you haven't beaten it yet right i have
not finished it yet okay on the last
encounter oh you're in the last account
okay okay last encounter is where we
called it casual
travis
tell what you said what you said i say
it again sir what happened
we're not doing that we're not doing it
did you beat the trap did you
no all right
i'm super casual apparently
i was waiting for the i was waiting for
the other side of that yeah you know i
got you
just from the start of this thing the
fact that we actually got to go inside a
pyramid ship and the architecture
architecture from the get-go the
aesthetics of the raid
so much is in this thing is just like
visually impressive to the art
art team
audio for kind of the background tones
like the music isn't quite in your face
as much but it fits the setting very
very well
yes yeah it fits the pyramid chip
ambience the darkness
um granted now if you play the last wish
and you had issues with symbols before
oh about to give a little crazier thank
you for saying a little crazier yep it
is there's there's a lot of stuff to go
on biggest thing you got to do is have
all your team agree there's a couple
pictures out there there's a couple we
made up that you know we had fun with
one was called green floyd instead of
pink floyd so we were having yeah that
was the prism one that i saw i also
called it the pink floyd that's so funny
yeah what y'all call the man the man
that's holding one thing and the thing
and then which i call that one that's
what that's where she's the witness oh
yeah call i just witnessed this okay
okay um we have like pizza slice though
we have like steak through the heart
like there are some crazy call-outs in
there because you're just trying to do
your best way to hold through the heart
i think that's what it was
yes that one we call it
that one we called iron man
that one we call trout that one we call
ty guy travis
with no heart in his chest oh my god oh
god stop it
we might have to change our our call not
even joking that was the call out that
was the that was the cause it was really
to call out in
where it's kind of like the praise the
sun but we were going to joke because
paul tassie did the meme when he finally
got his sword yes we were going to call
that the tassie for a little while but
we moved
back to
yeah the call-outs got very interesting
like the first encounter i did not know
a vehicle could go that fast by the way
so that was entertaining amazing amazing
i love doing it alone yes and we got to
do that afterwards on the mission um
yeah it was it was a challenge i mean
i'll i will say i got lucky i got as you
said i got to go with some all-stars um
i tripped into this team on twitter hold
on you can't casually trap we got to do
this like last week you got to name drop
this i'm going to i was getting
i didn't even have a group and then all
of a sudden i see like true vanguard
like hey i don't have a team it's like
okay and then and then i saw a cool guy
reply below that and we had him on the
last word as well great guy
um
and then i replied i was like hey i'm
still free agent as well and then below
that ascendant nomad also on the last
word
[Laughter]
a date for the prize
no that's not a rapey whole bunch of old
married dudes no no it was it was a
bunch of supermodels hanging out and
assuming that all of them yeah everybody
was playing yes they were like wait
we're all
yes nobody asked me to the date yet i
need a date yeah it get real serious we
found out when people don't get invited
to the date continue
and then the last two kj hovey hasn't
been as much in destiny in a while but
excellent sniper from d1 really well
known from that and then another guy
named jingleheimer that i didn't know
hilarious name but everybody like i will
absolutely say for his name
for raid groups
couldn't have been happier because
literally calm the entire time and i
think that's one thing that truly like
you know i probably stubbed my toe i
feel like i almost died maybe more than
everybody else like just on an average
number for me just because there's one
part of the third encounter which i was
holding and i had to basically jump into
hell to do what i had to do every so
often it was like those were moments but
everybody was just just chill take a
second cool guy was in here he was on
the firing range podcast and i heard him
describe how he was going to go into the
raid he's like hey i got my you know
alarm every couple hours stretch the
legs like take it nice and calm
um so yeah the raid group was honestly
very good but
second encounter which i think is where
a lot of people were getting dps checked
dps yeah
but just the way that second can count
because the first one we've done some
puzzle solving before i really liked it
and we'll go into the details
second encounter though and then when
you see more and more of the way this
works
honestly for me this is going to be a
this is
this is going to re this is going to be
way way up there
if you see the pantheon
this is definitely going to be up there
by the time we're all done i don't want
to take all the time though so travis i
had i got to the last encounter we're
looking at the final boss
and that's what we're going to head back
into tonight before we were yeah there
were a lot of like crashes we got kicked
basically once okay uh when we all
that's it that's it
yeah and then we fell down once
we're
literally
everybody got kicked and we're like okay
don't die a couple of us died but we
landed
and then we like were able to keep going
and then from there we were good so we
were very very lucky on that front wow
the bungie extended the 24-hour emblem
yeah 48 hours because hours of anteaters
and bugs and kicks and server crashes
and queues
all of that stuff in the introduction
was a struggle for everybody i don't
know if it ever fully got resolved for
some people if it was a struggle at
first we were very lucky i know but i
mean i also heard the team who got
world's first well three minutes ahead
of data which is just like oh data
second ago
he was three minutes and 15 seconds
but he also had the most viewed twitch
stream on twitch yesterday of everyone
he had 158 000 people watching him
when when i went to check i was like oh
i heard he won and i looked and i was
just like holy
so yeah he's probably doing fine again
he'll have a 315 merch shirt he's going
to be good he'll he'll turn that into a
business but yeah i was like second
again but he's he'll be he's the legend
he's a legend yeah real quick before i
pass the tribe i just wanted to ask like
for you personally i know what my moment
was but i wanted to get two moments like
one
what was a moment maybe without spoiling
that's too much i know king i don't know
if he wants any bars on that right so
like what was was there a moment for you
where you were like
okay this is a top raid and then the
second thing you see my background oh
yeah oh yeah oh man say no more say no
guys okay like literally just the world
i mean it was cool going up to the
pyramid ship and then kind of the first
encounter right after that first
encounter yes yes right after that was
the moment for me the horses were weird
with like 12 bucks which yeah yeah
i have no idea what's up with that
yeah but when you look over the edge i
just was like jaw dropped yeah yeah and
that's when it got to be
you look around and then later on i know
where you end up yeah
it's like a dungeon like you can see
where you end up and when i finally went
back on the mission you can replay
through today once it opened up okay and
the just the world in just the world
that they built inside of this pyramid
ship is like nothing i've ever seen in
destiny absolutely i can't explain the
horse butts oh we gonna get to it what
is that
what was the moment
that almost broke you if you could
remember
the encounter or just something with you
particularly you like man i don't know
he had a good team he was probably never
feeling it huh i was like in all as well
as let's say i was like i've had this
before like a tracks on deep stone crypt
we were there and it's like you have
different people come like saying this
thing or one person's not doing
i'm telling you like i got lucky but i
will say like even for me just a moment
when i know
the encounter that's after caretaker
which is just what it is the one yep but
it is
it takes a lot of polish on contest and
we got to the point where like if
there's stages i'm trying not to give
too much away
um
multiple stages into it we were getting
like okay we figured this one out
getting the polish down get the polish
down and it's just one of those moments
where i'm like okay it feels like a good
run we got this going on
i've got an important thing going on and
i basically like stubbed my toe and fall
down it's just like
yeah and it's like and it it's
you're not the only one and it happened
to everybody multiple times but it's one
of those where it feels like that i like
a good run yeah and then you just used
your own toe and it's like there's
there's nothing worse
and you
you there's a you're having a good run
and you see that red pop up and you're
like oh my god oh my god no no no no no
no no no you ever you ever you ever have
like the best player on the raid team
die and secretly you're like oh thank
god
it wasn't me it makes you feel like
you're you're
yeah you're like oh that that that like
errs me some credit so
like well you died once too
no no no don't absolutely all right
that's why i built my entire titan
around not dying like my entire titan
around not dying
3.0 was boy 3.0 was big for
probably almost all of us i think
actually yeah especially though i never
don't have an overshield it's crazy yeah
what was funny is when we was fighting
caretaker we would run out of a uh
a well so i would pop my show sideways
and give us all over shows yeah you can
do that sideways
rally barricade man rally barricade
actually is useful during a lot of the
encounters in this game that's what i'm
wearing so you should do it i got i got
a break protocol slovo backslap with a
super messy super chat
hey guys just wanted to show that the
chat is as disconnected from this
conversation as some destiny players
were disconnected from that raid
that's the perfect setup for trav
destiny players actually he's a division
player we never got disconnected i need
you to roll can you roast him he's a
division player like could you roll i
mean yeah you can't really talk on
destiny if you play division it's just
like it's like you know i mean what's
funny is like you can't get disconnected
from the division when no one's playing
you don't have login queues in the
description
there was the world's first get in to
get in
slow-mo do you also make fun of the
playstation ecosystem from your stadia
oh
yo
just curious i love the pattern i had
the sick travel i had to get traveled
but look chad what's up with you man
look you know world's first we talked
about it on last word this week which
was an amazing episode chris ray gunn in
the building you know what i'm saying
oh yeah absolutely i love that we was
able to do that on on friday and just
get you in but um look man like how was
it give me the give me the team
construct give me the highs the lows i
wasn't trapped
oh you know it's real
so i might for first of all i have to
comment on the review thing of course a
studio has nothing to do with how good a
game is right like the the review it's
all about the game you shouldn't take
any other factors into account so that
that i i have to comment on yeah okay of
course of course
yes um
so my raid situation was kind of
different i i don't have a dream team i
basically paired up with a funny
streamer because i figured we would make
jokes the whole time and i nailed it it
was me and d flawless seeing backstreet
boys and just like just just chilling
the other look at travis fellaini and
blaming it all oh this is that happened
we just sing backstreet boys
listen i've played with travis before
pause and we had a great time yeah so i
understand your philosophy and going
because you know it was going to be a
bunch of stress travis went into the
right now and he wasn't
listen all i heard was travis
i i've played with ray teams that were
sweaty and on day one it always turns
into a fight like even if even if
everything's going well oh did we have
one
and the thing and then yeah we had an
outburst once yes good evening yeah i
just i just wanted a break from that
like i i was already stressed out enough
by
life stuff and i'm running on like 12
hours of sleep for the week right so
like i was just like d flawless you're
the perfect guy you're funny you have
super positive energy you're always
singing we have kind of like the same
type of personality let's just do it
together the other four people on our
stream were kind of try hearts they were
like
sherpa types oh that's probably i feel
like that would be worse
it was a bad mixture
he said y'all too nuts was inside there
with the wait the way travis was
describing this right team i thought all
they're gonna be like this it's like he
only told us half the pro equation so
here's here's the thing though but the
the people that were trihards they were
also like very calm and there were no
fights let me just
there were no fights yesterday the the
problem was that we went in and we were
just crushing it right like we just blew
our way through that first opening
encounter and then we got our fir we got
our first dc and it really took the wind
out of our sails and then it happened
two more times and it and we had to
repeat the encounter three times
and then we got into the first encounter
finally it didn't crash on us
and
uh we started getting dc'ed for four or
five hours
four or five hours so i i would i
actually didn't start playing the raid
until like 3 p.m in earnest
in between all of the uh disconnects in
between all of the disconnects um the
rally barricades weren't work or the
routes weren't working
you couldn't do the rally banner at all
it was it would take like a minute for
it to register dude for us it would take
like five minutes it got to the point
where we were we were going to orbit and
then landing after every reset just so
we can oh
no it was it was nasty
like this that's bad this lasted for so
long it just left such a bad taste of
mouth and honestly even though our team
was super solid the wind was it was just
like getting punched in the stomach like
we just got
and so we beat the first encounter it
only took us like maybe 90 minutes to
beat that first one and then we got to
the second encounter by this point as i
said we got a really late start because
of all the issues it's like maybe five
or six p.m
and we spent like maybe uh we spent from
6 p.m to 4 a.m during that encounter uh
we were going in completely blind so we
didn't have any guides
yeah i dude i was i was playing i went
to bed at five and i woke up at seven
for the big couch yeah you had
i slept for two hours last night so yeah
yeah so do you need me to send you a
pair of shades yes please that'd be
great and a shot of rum please i need a
little hair in the dark
so yeah the uh yeah so so uh we we were
we figured out the encounter we were
starting to get dps ebontus hopped in
and helped us figure out the mechanics
because at a certain point the blind
mechanics weren't really working because
i it wasn't that we couldn't figure it
out it was that we we got close enough
to figuring out how to do it and then we
were all so tired that we just sort of
were like on autopilot for a couple
hours and then uh we we got to the final
boss uh of that encounter and uh
couldn't do dps and then decided to call
it a night so
my i don't really have i wasn't
expecting the 24 hour thing i was
expecting that worst case scenario i'd
finish the raid today right and now i
can't do that because cut this motor's
down
here's the bad thing is that i'm going
to have to delay my final review right
by the day i already talked to my editor
and he was just like dude don't kill
yourself because i didn't really i
didn't really put i didn't really put
today aside today i was supposed to
finish all the end game missions that
have popped up which i just got spoiled
on the final boss because of the cuts
because of cutscene yeah
thanks for that bungie uh and uh i uh i
i have to finish all the like quests and
get my exotic glaive and all that and
once i once i finished that then i'll uh
i'll be able to write my review and all
that stuff but i have to finish the raid
so that means i'm i'm probably going to
be doing it tomorrow i didn't really set
today aside to do it but that said
there's any team that's already
completed it and for whatever reason
they want to go through it with me today
uh if the contest was still active i
would accept your inventions yes hit up
the dms slide in the dms just put it out
there real quick travel before i pass it
off um
what was that moment for you
right that you oh i got it okay i've
gotten this the moment i realized it was
going to be a great rate is the moment i
realized i was right because i've been
saying for months that they were going
to introduce at least a glimpse of the
new mob
right and as soon as as soon as uh
rhombus or whatever his name was started
talking
uh i was i was like this is it it's like
we're gonna we're gonna fight the
disciples shall we follow the disciple
obviously but uh i was i was like this
is it like we're gonna get a sneak
preview of what's to come in destiny and
that's what that's what i was hoping for
i was hoping that it would it would only
work but
oh yeah let's talk about the horsepower
yeah
i do have an explanation for the
horsepower so um if you ever go to like
uh ancient europe or you go to europe
and you look at the ancient european
history they have these weird like
museums where it's collections of old
like ancient statues that were like
people testing things out and there's
weird stuff like that there's like
people with like three heads because
they were they were practicing the head
and they're all connected and if you
walk into these rooms it's super creepy
and it looks just like the inside of the
pyramids and so and you see stuff like
that like people will be practicing
horses so it'll be like a long block of
cylinder with like a bunch of heads on
it and so clearly it's like this guy
this collector is like
scavenging like you know old history of
like things that were left behind from
uh societies that collapsed so the the
horse butts is like a dead ringer for
some of the stuff i saw when i visited
like ancient rome and like some stuff
like that so uh i i think that that's
what they're alluding to like a lot of
the architecture and the statues are
like weird like body torture you know
body horror or like bodybuilder
yeah man
crazy and then what was what was the
moment that almost almost broke trap
questioning almost broke me honestly it
was just it it's what it always is which
is just the attrition of staying up
forever
none of the encounters were super hard
to be honest um i i have a feeling that
as soon as contest mode is over we're
going to get right
oh we're going to do a lot of this yeah
it's going to be crazy like especially
the encounter i'm on now which we're
just going to blow through it like i
already already we have the we have the
motions down pat it's really just doing
dps so let me let me ask a question
right um from a super relaxed player
because you said you know casual and you
said you're super casual i'm super
apparently
right i'm
i
super
relaxed i knew for a fact that i wasn't doing
that day one crap because yeah um
the level of stress that goes into it
and then when somebody looks over at you
and like you're dying too much
sure
yeah yeah all right so
that's why i could feel lee bontis when
ebanta says you know uh yo it felt like
i was dying a lot or whatever so when
you know somebody else died i felt a
little bit good or something like that
and and i get that and i understand that
because i look over attack because taker
say something and then he'll die and i
go uh-huh
oh shoot out yeah just like that's the
biggest thing for something like this is
you need to check
rey like egos attitudes it's just like
work together and just know everybody's
going to screw up yes you have to have
that mentality you have to you have to
have the right team for sure right
because a lot of dudes go in there with
their egos so
and and and it's
warranted because a lot of you guys like
when you said imantus didn't have a
group i was like kind of shocked to be
honest with you right because you expect
oh ivanta's got a group you know all his
videos are solo videos
yeah
that makes sense ty but um
my question is and and i know it sounds
ignorant and me saying this but i never
do day ones anyway so what is for
anybody that doesn't know what is this
um like this contest more competitive
mode that y'all keep talking about i
don't understand do they make it harder
basically what they do they basically
lower the um
they they cap the power that you're at
so that you're 20 below the encounter
and they and they're always
they're all red bars they put you at a
very uh large disadvantage and then uh
you're also doing less damage to all the
enemies so basically it means that you
can't really not only do you have to get
mechanics correct it's pretty much
perfect but then you also have to be
doing an incredibly high level damage
which means that you have to have a deep
understanding of the meta the armor mods
the weapon types how they interplay with
each other perks you probably have to
have uh grinded for god rolls and like a
really good like armor set so that your
stats are correct and if you don't have
all that stuff you're probably not going
to make it all right i would say i would
say they nailed it on this one like they
made it so that like that razor thin
margin is getting through and anybody
who doesn't make the cut no chance in
hell so then okay so it automatically
eliminates the casual like any any dude
that goes in there and it's not sitting
there putting his uh his build together
uh don't know uh how what grenade feeds
off of uh what rift or or or what gun
feeds into uh what overshield and stuff
like that because a lot of times now i'm
looking at certain things i'm like okay
i am getting a deeper understanding
because they switched up a lot of stuff
for us right now yeah and i'm getting a
deeper understanding that sometimes if
you kill an enemy with a certain gun you
get an overshield right so if you're
going there with that gun and you're
saying that they put you at 20 below
that over show becomes super important
because you're a weakened point all
right i'm trying to understand it yeah
and enter today
tomorrow
tomorrow it'll be normal yeah so yeah
you'll be at like if the first
encounters will probably be like 5 25 30
and if you're at 550 you're just going
to be 30 above them crushing it the
final encounter will probably be 15 50
would be mine i would guess yeah i feel
like it's gonna be yeah could like 15 30
was contest
and even though you're 15 50 yeah it's
like you're gonna be below that one and
then it seems to creep up as you go
through each one of the encounters yeah
final boss does feel like 15 50 cents i
always i always say that destiny and
really games in general aren't made for
streamers and there's a lot of dialogue
around destiny of like streamers going
hey this is wrong about pvp and they're
trying to make changes
that are for them they're not for the
average player anytime that happens i'm
like dude you guys are out of your minds
this game isn't for you like you guys
are part of it but it's for just like
people want to play the game but contest
mode is for streamers okay that is like
the one part of the destiny that is made
for them and they they did a really good
job this time at making it aside from
all the technical bugs i know i'm super
pissed at bungie right now for for uh
rolling it out that way i
you know other than that they nailed it
i actually think contest mode
is helping with like casualizing the
raid because
it makes it to where when you go into
the raid everyone's at the same level
and especially they've made it so easy
to get to that that that cap now like
you pretty much only had to do the
legend mode
and you was
pretty much right ready at that point
like just a little bit beyond how hard
is the
that's kind of wild it's pretty you
could have done normal you could have
probably gotten to 15 30
whether you did the legendary campaign
or not and honestly like i did every
character solo that's a normal thing for
me but
like whether you do it as a team would
you do it solo the legendary campaign it
was actually easier to do it yeah it was
actually easier easier yeah it scaled
differently
i paired in later for the final fight in
case somebody hasn't got there yet and
yeah it's beefier there for sure but
you can get to 15 30. that doesn't mean
somebody who just bought witch queen did
the last campaign and then gets into
that is gonna be able to
i mean regardless if they do it or not
that that's that's besides the point i'm
saying it makes everything more even or
not necessarily yeah you mean like it
makes it easier
it makes it easier to step in the right
and know that you know besides knowledge
you're pretty much on the same level as
much time
i like that they gave them a path
you can be 15 30 power and still have
god roll weapons and goggle armor and
compete with the best so i actually i
really appreciate they did that because
it means the previous contests you also
had there was a race on raid day but
there was also a race the week before
i remember
the worst time i've ever felt in destiny
is when i we did the last wish day one
and i was so
underpowered you cannot you can ask hogg
i we put so many hours into coming up
into that day one and i almost like i
was mentally defeated the moment the
game started pretty much because it's
like dude i can understand but the the
part that just annoyed me it's like i
could understand if i didn't low light
the game but i did and i'm still under
level yeah i remember you were yeah you
were pissed i remember that yeah there
was a point with more rng there and
things like that and they've and they've
learned i mean they've heard the
feedback they've put the conversation
to their credit they fixed it yeah i've
always felt like destiny needs to be
more about knowledge and skill and not
about grinding level that's just
something yeah that was that was the
thing that was you're preaching to the
choir right here dude i say that on last
word all the time like why do they want
you to do the same activity a million
times i just want to like yeah but we'll
just like everybody grind strikes and
crucible before you yeah
they're still kind of saying that in a
way yeah
yeah so let's open it up before i get
out of here we gonna have our discussion
uh i want to talk to our resident that's
the expert lord sovereign you know you
did not take take part this week you
know i was we were looking he's still
qualified as a destination
he didn't take part he he left us for
the best
so i just want to know you know as the
uh the hardcore destiny player that you
are you know what was your experience
looking in
um
i just have to say that uh i know now
why you guys switched over the podcast
to a general gaming podcast
good good move good move
i hate you
um
no it was fun watching you guys yeah i
had to look at my support you know my
little twenty dollars
words of encouragement yesterday you
know uh and fantastic words of
encouragement but
no god bless you guys okay
you're right you can't do this right now
what can i say but i mean
the dedication you guys have is
something really special but um it's
psychotic
economic is a good way to put in travis
psychotic is
is like
it didn't feel like 12 hours like i felt
like i turned around and it was nine
like that's the crazy part i
know i want to go
continue i just love but i said that the
dynamic of watching you guys raid period
it is absolute gold it is gold because
again it like like like you know like
travis said monster said you have to
check your eagles at the door when
you're playing iop no one checks egos at
the door like none of that is happening
actually you you would be proud we only
had one outburst in this world but you
had a bunch of you heard
yeah
so what i was able to watch what she was
able to watch i went to see the batman
um
no it's just the initial parts of you
guys trying to figure stuff out and the
figuring stuff out part is really fun to
see just because it is everybody going
in blind you have no idea and then the
thing about these encounters is that
they always sort they're always
multifaceted right and it always
requires some sort of
cooperation in terms of like you're
doing this i'm doing this and it's like
that's very cool i've always respected
that about destiny raids um it's just
it's it's not for me
but i i i'm the first person to
discourage people from playing destiny
for sure i'm like people people ask me
all the time should i get into destiny
and i'm like no
but now now i really feel like the
answer is like really no like it's it's
really hard i guess for a new person to
come in like in terms of the lore like
so much stuff has changed what have they
done what have they done at to to
onboard somebody brand new saying hey
i'm jumping in with this they did one
thing nothing they did one thing which
is they brought the everybody's power
level up so that you can play the screen
expansions and that sucked but other
than that destiny is harder to get into
now than it ever has been yeah and
they're new that's like garbage that's
in my review yeah dude i have a friend
who played destiny back in the day he
played a little bit of destiny 2 dropped
off and then he logged on to play witch
queen and he was like why am i is isn't
this the first mission from destiny 1
why am i playing this he was like so
confused
yeah everything they changed about it is
just very unique so but does that change
help sort of onboard people where it's
like okay because at first i thought
they retconned all of that and it was
like that doesn't even the only good
thing that those beginning missions did
because my girlfriend just did is it
does give newer destiny players the
opportunity to get some exotics that we
had to grind for a little bit but
besides that the tutorial is horrible
they don't really explain much of
anything you don't even get your sparrow
off the bat so you have to walk
everywhere for the for a good portion of
it really oh wow yeah
it's not good man and i i keep i talk i
talk about this in my review but like if
you're a new player it's it's so
daunting and all that added new
currencies in this expansion it's it's
you can't
i was in the chat going like what are
you talking about he was like well you
can see them if you hover over perks and
i'm like that's not that's not big
that's not the only reason that it's
there is because they want to show you
okay it's imagine if it wasn't there and
you just didn't know why it's not
working
i do want to add i actually think it was
new rad who said that yeah i think you
can do what i say so i want to ask you
you can't it's more of like he was
stating a fact but yeah it's like it's
not it's not yes but you for like to
sob's question and i'll open it up for
um king is that a reference to the
campaign lore though i mean as far as
like the
destiny having an actually good campaign
because i think even though soft doesn't
play really good yeah like even though
son of a player probably never going to
be a destiny player and there's a lot of
people to chat it's like oh my god what
are they talking about
but like could you explain to him like
in your opinion as far as storytelling
for this campaign in a pocket
how would you explain that to him
it's like i'm so in to
i'm not like on destiny's lord nerd
level i'm not on a bytes level not under
my own level i've
you know consumed a lot of their content
so i have an idea what's going on
so going into this one
i got more out of this story because i
had some background right because there
was an idea of like i have heard of this
person before even got a reference of
seeing you know we got a technically a
graphical drawing of zebra wrath for the
first time like there were certain
little things that i noticed but i also
say
it is one of the coolest destiny
campaigns even if you probably don't
know
just to experience like the voices and
the character you meet and then the
world that you experience and then what
happens towards the end of the campaign
just the fact of this is like this is a
turning point for storytelling in
destiny yes we've been building up to
this over the last few seasons of
splicer season of the chosen season of
the lost we've been building these
storytelling
actual kind of cohesion and then this is
a really good culmination of the past
three seasons and now we get to this
campaign and i'm just excited to see
what comes in the future seasons what
happens in lightfall because of what
happened in this one and the quality of
what we got i would say even if you just
played destiny for the st the story like
hey you play through the campaign chill
you like and if you get the deluxe
edition that's up to you it's like you
even log in like hey i'm gonna play
tuesday for like an hour just to keep up
with the story it's at a point where
it's actually worth doing that
and then if you feel like you get
addicted to like hey i'll play little
strikes i'll experiment with weapon
crafting there's some other stuff
convoluted or not but just getting the
story beats over the course of the year
is a fun journey to be on at this point
to me yeah
i always say that uh destiny is graded
on a destiny curve where like
people players who play destiny will be
like oh forsaken was a pretty good story
for destiny
that's a good point but the witch queen
is genuinely a good campaign and a good
story period not just for destiny
actually good which is like that's the
that is the first time this has ever
happened for this franchise i i mean i
criticized destiny's story all the time
for being a little too eu you know they
they rely super heavily on the stuff
that doesn't happen in the game and this
is the first time we're like you can
play a destiny story and be like damn
destiny's got some story chops which i
did not see coming yes salute to the
nation
so that that's very interesting to me
right that the fact that yeah it's it's
in the everything is in the game play
and the story the cut scenes everything
you're not going into like you what are
they called the group cards
yeah
you don't have to log on weekly to see
what crow is up to you just play it you
see the cut scenes you experience the
story and at the end you go damn that
was good that's good okay no doubt
so let's open up king before i'm give it
to you then i'll let attic and me go
last um how you feeling man what you
heard i know you stayed away you
intelligently stayed away from the first
no it's strategically
strategically i i let fools rush in
and and
and i'll sit back and i'll uh get your
knowledge
and then i will come in on when when the
cap is removed and my level is respected
um
and do my thing because i don't care to
be first i just care to be uh getting it
done and get whatever exotics out of it
and you know having fun
i don't think there's fun day one i
really absolutely don't i i left you
guys on i fell asleep to you guys i was
watching you guys all the way through so
i was part of the that that that number
the consistent number
you know so he was part of the right you
just wasn't part of the raid oh no i
laughed i laughed so much because like
you you you say there there was one big
blow up yeah one big blow up but it was
constant snipes throughout
like like it was constant
[Music]
of and i could i felt the build up and i
was like
like you're here for the best of this
when when one dude run through the door
and you hear the guy coming out open the
door at the door
please be at your position and then you
have somebody snipe at you and say attic
don't go over there like and i'm like
it's going to happen
you're just waiting for the mess
it's going to have friendships shall be
launched oh bro
we won't be talking for a couple of
weeks and we'll get back to you
recovered well we're recovering no but
y'all did i'm proud
my thing is and like you guys have been
alluding to it's a great story i thought
they answered a ton of questions yes
from because a lot of times destiny
leaves stuff ambiguous right and they
leave it up to
oh oh next time maybe
no they answered every question
going through until he even got to
bubble head t-boy at the end
with the turtleneck and mount public
[Music]
so and i said the story i i felt they
learned from disney
um
in sympathizing and empathizing with the
villain
it made you feel for her story like wow
yeah she was protecting her brothers and
sisters
and you know and and
taking king
for me was like their best they was
that's when they hit their stride
i think this was leaps and bounds and
they perfected it in the point where
like you said from from from that's 79 i
tell people pay the 79 dollars all right
pay the 79. let's go don't start change
yourself go inside get everything that
you're gonna get you'll be good with the
two dungeons for the next five years and
all that other stuff but the story
itself and the ability to either use
casual or use legendary mode was
fantastic and like you said if you're
going through by yourself you add
somebody else into it because i noticed
i was taking dudes down with one gallon
shot when i was by myself
i do to jump in
now it's a gala horn shot and a couple
of pulse
[Music]
and rifles it's five gallon horn shots
the three
the three scaling is ridiculous
it turned it into a minute what's funny
is when we was playing it i just thought
that's the way it was i didn't know
there was all this scaling to this i
thought it was
and then the tokens yeah the tokens then
it turns into i still wish they would
take tokens out no i don't i love it
because you can blame people i love the
blame people you know they're like hey
i'm sorry i already used my tokens
[Music]
you know what the worst thing is is when
you're like yo i need to be revived and
the person here is like i already used
my token on you a minute ago like i
can't revive you again
we're going to die because of you
there's nothing there's nothing worse
than you walking around and they're like
a revive and i'm like dude i already did
i can't remember everybody don't want it
i use my tongue
i get what he's saying but like without
the revive tokens there would be no
challenge you could just yeah i think
the revi i think the tokens are
important right
it forces you because remember
remembering the taking king when we got
killed by like certain moves that oryx
did really it's cool we'll just revive
everyone like yeah yeah
real sense of danger it was just like
let's just rewind all it took was one
person surviving and the whole raid was
fine not now
now that that is very important and you
train them up
during this you know the legendary mode
and then you get the perks and stuff so
i'm doing legendary mode with monkey
yeah and i'm teaching them as we're
going through and we don't want nobody
else to join like
let's keep it with
but the story itself and and
the the level of um
architect in the world it's so expansive
it it leaves us so much possibilities
right
but when they told you
all the way through this is why this guy
was here he was never really here it was
she was the the queen of lies can you
really trust them do you really trust
this person that's talking to you this
uh this little ghost do you really trust
what he's saying can you trust this and
the story brings you in and it gives you
a payoff right so if you never do the
raid
and you just do this story
it gives you a payoff
it's not like for the casual dude oh you
got to do the raid to get the real end
bro
and maybe
when i do the raid i i'll get something
else out of it but it it seems like more
of an option too not a requirement of
right
no fair enough fair enough the last
segment for me my bro attic man 12 hours
blood sweat tears we've been through it
all you know um
just in general like what's your fault
like what the fourth day one raid we've
done yeah it's like the fourth yeah
we've been rocking for a minute bro i'm
gonna get y'all a shirt yeah we've been
wrong and you haven't finished any of
them huh
what's funny
is
we got stuck on that second encounter uh
the the the first real encounter for so
long because we didn't realize that all
of them had to be on one obviously like
like we i figured from like
from past history
it would all be on individual ones and
then they would come together eventually
so we see we said what probably two
hours not realizing the most key factor
of that mechanic because we kept saying
we got to be missing something we got to
be missing something yeah yeah yeah i
wanted to ask you don't like jessica
because you you this is what you played
sd for if if destiny did not have rage
you would have been done and i might i
would have quite a long time yeah long
time ago so my question for you
specifically is i know it's early we
didn't do the whole thing yet clearly
but
so far
how is it feeling to you does it feel
like a top tier raid or you know just
where you at with it
i think i'd give it so far i got to say
the taking king's still ahead of it
um
the last wish even might be out of it i
don't know maybe they're a little bit
tied because i really enjoyed the last
wish like
i really enjoyed it but it i haven't
played the last encounter and people
tell me that's where this particular
race shines
oh boy before even to be honest
the encounter we're on with the you're
on caretaker yeah we don't care taken
the caretake i saw we got to do it
yeah just shout out first of all we got
shout out to team you know what i'm
saying shout out this girl what scream
shout out to frosty he was really cool
new guy
very calm we had like our ivantis
presence he was just so calming like i
was just like i like you i could go to
war with you you know what i'm saying
shout out to you shout out to frost
because me and cindy bicker at each
other like can't we all just get along
like we did good
but i give us credit normally the blow
up will happen early it took about nine
hours for that breath
for that first blow up yeah it was it
was it was and then we you know we had
to calm down we everybody had to go big
corner most people for nine minutes nine
hours a shout out shout out to gamer
forte keep it keeping exactly for
keeping the the spirit light and and
being funny and getting everybody to
jump into each other after we really
kill each other
like
okay the first thing i want to talk
about is the story yeah i personally
felt like the story has had a come up
since the saint 14 season like you know
it might not have been
the greatest at that point but i think
that's when they finally started
realizing the way they wanted to move
destiny in terms of seasons because
during that saint 14th season i enjoyed
every every week like i don't know
uh you know this
i feel like every season has been good
at lord
covering it's just certain events aren't
fun or you know i don't think it's been
the story that's been the issue with
destiny it's been everything else
it's been the crucible lag lusting
support it's been the the weather that's
still a problem yeah yeah yeah
it's been the way that oh we're gonna
sunset oh we're not sunsetting like like
i've always felt like the biggest
problem with destiny is bungie because
they never feel like they hold their
ground on anything like the moment
something happens they just pull the
trigger oh you guys don't like that
back up back up
listening to your fans is the worst and
best thing you could do depending on
what you're you know what you're
standing by yeah yeah and as far as like
as far as this raid though the story and
the raid
i i like the raid i like the aesthetics
of the raid now
the aesthetics is good
i didn't really
the first like raid thing where you're
on the ship thing like that didn't
really do nothing for me like it was
cool but i didn't really do nothing in
terms of
you know i've always liked that the
mechanic of opening something you know
what i'm saying like like where you have
to like build pillars or what was the
first one and and the taking king what
was that first encounter i didn't you
don't fight i'd ever like that that was
the terms i didn't like to learn
the totems was further into it no it was
where you got to grab the stuff and then
you got the rhyme to dunk them yeah it
was the first one absolutely i've always
liked yeah i've always liked
raid mechanics like that like it was
cool but i felt like that particular
part could have been a little bit better
um as far as like i'm a bit i'm a huge
boss fan that's probably why the taking
king's always going to be there because
they had they had really good boss you
and he bought the [ __ ]
yeah so it it's been a good race it's
been solid right now it's like i said i
i do feel like
the taking king's still better because
i'm sorry wait for the final if you
haven't looked it up just wait for the
final box and hold your judgement wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on mind
you eventually
he he is with you as far as king's fall
be his favorite so for e to say that
that's something
it's the main reason is because i'm just
gonna say this
i know the type of games you and i both
like
and i know what type of
kind of nod we're gonna get in the boss
fight and it's
let's just say we haven't experienced it
like this before because i know what's
coming i looked because i want to knock
it out tonight
i guess
part of me that that's a little it's not
that i'm frustrated i'm disappointed
as you guy like cog especially can
probably like that i've been a huge
where i can't wait to fight sabbath dude
i can't wait to fight sabbath dude like
because i was such a huge fan of the
actual you know of the king oryx that i
was kind of disappointed with what her
thing ended because like i wanted to
fight her in the raid like i understand
you know we got something better in
terms of laura in the raid
but i overhyped myself for sabbath
and i personally did not feel like what
i got with sabathune was good enough
like i like you know sheep she brought
hot you know hive guardians and that was
cool
but like i remember like or starting and
he like he didn't he didn't
start a new ad but he did he did the
taking which was all the ads with new
abilities so i i like that you know i
felt like he was more intimidating he
was more present like when he showed up
he showed up like you didn't really
let's be real sabaton wasn't really in
that expansion much like she talked to
you but like i'm pretty sure hive
guardians would kick the crap out of
every take in the run run the board so
heim guardians are a new
i i get what you're saying like taken
brought an entire theoretical like race
into the game of taking even if they
were kind of reskinned i guess
just me it's like
part of me just tired of the over usage
of the same as we've been fighting since
2013. yeah and it's just
i would get that right
i would have preferred the hive
guardians to champion i hate champions
yeah i don't i don't like champions
because they make me use stuff i don't
want to use yeah i'd rather have to
fight that's real i'd rather have a
night ha like have i would rather have
all the abilities be passed on and they
have the the light than just fight these
but that's besides the fact it's like
i've always felt like destiny
is in the best place when it's hard
and that they did do that good like i
can't say that
they uh this this raid was good man it's
just like
it's like i said like in terms of until
i beat the raid i can't really say if it
is but right now yeah i would have to
put
you still got it for right now
look let me let me get my balls off
there we go because i know poor solve is
suffering and we gotta move on but um
look you know
i will say this
this week i look at my life sometimes
like
this week proves why like destiny and
raiding in my opinion is the greatest
cooperative experience in gaming because
it's like
there's no game
i'm gonna average two to three hours of
sleep
i'm gonna do a 12 hour stream
i am going to have friends of mine get
into spats prior to the raid on who the
raid team is going to be
that's what you know what dude's like yo
you know you scream i gotta call you i
love you scream he's like yo you know i
thought i was going to beat it i'm like
bro i didn't know you was interested you
you've been my yay you know so the fact
that he loves it so much and all of us
love it so much that dudes want to
solidify they spot right so that's when
you know people love something right
you know how you know it's it's real cog
when you're going to uh some type of
event some type of
you know rating and you know
there's a good chance it's going to be
beef at some point yeah it's going to be
exactly right because we love it too
much right so that that's the first day
but to the raid itself
wow fantastic job the aesthetic like for
me king
i think king is going to really touch
king because me and king have always
been
on our what we're going to call it our
egyptian to the essence almond raw
motif to the essence for the culture
right of course your trials of osiris
i'm trying to silence them besides but
but this is fun
shut up he's not a fraud shut up
shout out shout out to that aspect no
that's savage i've never laughed
so hard
because
my man and and i got a chance to get
everybody here in the room
i understand how long
he was capping for this dude oh
right that's right
the god of gods the warlock of warlocks
the unstoppable sabbath
for the last last month i loved i loved
the messy part of it and they and they
left it like that never him he was never
there and i used his body and you
you sir
have been capping for me for three
months
and i actually
loved that like i did so you know it's
funny king
the way they told that story people
started singing like that's what i'm
saying like they've been okay at
storytelling for a while now like not
for sure no it's dope it's actually
dope like it was so many different
moments in this story and revelations
and honesty and and just real like it it
questioned their religion yes this is
their religion they looked up at the
trial like this is the holy spirit of
whatever it is and it was like he's
giving it out to everyone yeah yeah for
sure
it
no i was just gonna say that whole line
of the line between light and dark is so
very thin is becoming more and more and
more prevalent as we go forward i just
enjoyed the fact that they're flirting
with what's good and what's bad yeah the
last thing i'll say is like i said you
know for you king
again like this to me without spoiling
is the most of that theme that that that
egyptian to the essence and there's even
a part where i literally felt like i am
in
a civilizations museum
and it was just so and it's very ominous
and you're like i get the sense of what
they're doing as far as this entity and
what's about to happen and it's a
beautiful up for the future and if the
future is that i'm they're in like
they're in such a good place right now
that i'm super excited lore wise i am
not even worried
i will say one thing what's up they got
to do better on supporting that pvp
because like regardless how much we
don't care for it yeah we've always
talked about it
yeah
what what i was saying though is like
pvp is what's going to escalate destiny
where it used to be
pvp would carry it and until they
address that i don't think you're ever
truly going to have like destiny come
back to how it used to be yeah you talk
about overall overall the the the whole
package of destiny i'm just talking
about the rail that's what i'm talking
about right now
yeah
yes do you do you think now that the the
foundation
uh because we feel that they're in a
great space uh story-wise right do you
do you think now uh destiny uh tries to
make that that that leap mean that us
they have the backing of
a major or if not the number one the
number two uh uh movie studio in the
business uh they make that leap too oh
yeah
that's that's just to them they already
said they want to
yeah because i was i was talking to
somebody they were saying it was a
little bit blasphemous for me even
saying this but i said
this is our modern day star wars right
and and the only thing that is missing
by the diet and stuff
i'm a huge star wars dude right but i'm
talking about modern day this is my
clunky in the building you may have said
i'm going to continue yeah yeah yeah
but
just just just follow me here the only
thing that is missing here because uh
what they did was they followed one
family's story
inside star wars
that's the only thing that's missing
here they followed the high school story
in theory because you got sabbath and
zebra right
that's that is one of the things i
actually really enjoyed about this
expansion is we got more history yes
about anything in destiny than i think
we ever have because the idea of
guardians being a clean slate we don't
get a lot of what what happened during
the golden age we don't know much if
anything besides like little bits here
and there and i'm sure there's some lore
that i don't know but to go all the way
back to
proto-hive and
and worm gods and getting the background
and that's why i kind of say like for
somebody like sav do you want to jump in
have you ever watched the biff video you
know if you haven't they're going to
give you the in-game version of what
we've been consuming from by for a while
and you're actually going to get to
experience that level of storytelling
from like the history of a villain and
why and as as you said like the villain
aramis was kind of a start in beyond
light we got a feel of like you got a
little sympathy you knew what you wanted
to do traveler turned her back she found
the darkness she found another way to go
after him this is a different one we got
to see
deception on multiple multiple levels
for like i mean ancient ancient however
many new like thousands of years of
history
and then to come around and see the way
this thing turns about in the end no
that's i i 100 percent think
it's exciting
loki found out that one of the uh enemy
factions
could have completely went a different
route yeah yeah good travel then i
finished my business is my mic good by
the way it's better
it's not better i can turn it up more
yeah turn up a little bit i'll uh i'll
i'll
kind of turn it on your head that's
somebody who thinks about star wars
about 15 hours a day yeah i actually
think destiny is star wars in reverse so
okay star wars became well known because
it tells really good stories in its
world and it benefits by the fact that
it doesn't really do a lot of world
building because it doesn't want you to
focus on like how does the ship get made
or yeah what how does this planet mine
for its oxygen it doesn't want you to
think about that it wants you to think
about like
why does why do we care about luke and
what's his relationship to these people
the story of the family yeah it's a
story of the people there and they've
had to do the world building in post
right destiny is the exact opposite
where they have an incredible world
building and they've built the world
excellently but they have a really hard
time telling stories in it thank you and
i i think that what they're trying to do
with movies and tv is say well we've got
this great world let's tell stories in
it my my question is
is that going to work and i i kind of
think it's going to be hard for them
because i think you have to get people
to care about the things in your world
and then i think star wars did it in the
right order basically right i worry that
destiny trying to do it the other way
people aren't going to care about those
movies or tv show but because they're
going to say that's not what destiny's
about destiny is about this cool world
where i can shoot guns and i don't
really care about its characters and i
think they've sort of done that to
themselves and that's what i was saying
because uh you don't have
those key people like luke
uh and you know his sister and and why
is darth vader so prevalent you know
it's it's the story when you find out
that this is this and this leads to that
that that one
storyline is what held star wars
together if you actually really look at
it yeah and here like you said you have
this wonderful world
but who's the character that you care
about the most addict just said that he
has no idea that his character was an
exo right you know until he took the
helmet off the empty vessel yeah
weirdly the character i care about most
is finch a character i just said exactly
the new guy yeah yeah right like is he a
liar is he this is he that what's what's
what's up with fitch why his little
thing broke i think that might be the
reason that they want to do
more in terms of tv show and movies so
they can
make some of these back histories
because some of these things
the way they want to do it it's got to
be told in like a cinematic way not a
game way
look i just finished my bars um yeah man
it was it was it was a tremendous
experience i think the tension i think e
is kind of on the same point i'm on i
thought the music is underrated from an
ominous standpoint and then as the
encounters continue on you'll start to
see the tension rise to let you know
you're getting there and i think there
was a moment in attic with the they
still won't work nothing at the video
game awards yeah they won't get you of
course of course you know they're gonna
get that so you got that story
you
surprised if it happened but yeah it's a
frenetic thing shout out to the raid
weapons they look really cool i saw like
that little um the thing going on i know
what you're talking about
yeah
they got something
shout out to the webcam chat somebody
mods please handle your business today
yeah yeah yeah yeah they they they've
been in our stream for 12 hours they
were trying to get their website off but
a salute to them but um yeah
other than that like i want to say that
again shout out to team elysium who did
it um they got back-to-back
championships as far as that i do want
to say
this is the last dude yeah i will i
won't want to say though it would be
this we have to address the issues
though now surprisingly
we didn't have one
not one issue not one flag raid bound or
issues we didn't get disconnected we
didn't get throw to orbit
like when i'm hearing everybody else
i was like really really like yeah we
were like you know what like like we had
the most cleanest
i think matter of fact the only time i
knew something may have been off was
caretaker there was one time we started
the encounter and i felt like there were
hardly any ads one time you don't say at
the start when you started right but but
but towards the end it was always like
that because we just we found out we'll
be your responsibilities yeah me and you
got efficient on on this morning and we
let forteon sin distract the caretaker
while scream and frost was doing
anything inside the room getting the
symbols and coming back out but i will
say like i was shot when i heard it i
was like wow so many people had issues
so yeah like they got to look into that
and and obviously as a result then we
found out that contest mode got extended
right so you're like yo what's going on
so i do feel for the people who really
suffered behind that like that's
demoralizing if you get kicked
especially yeah like travel running yeah
can i
top and and let's say you had to be
disconnected i think that you're going
to to see how
to see how much data
got disconnected and how did that affect
his time
yeah
i mean i would be hugely pissed off if
we got disconnected a bunch of times and
that really affected how our flow went
and stuff like that because then it's
really on them and not on us yeah i mean
let's be honest with you
like i know a lot of people was upset
and they wanted like the raid
race to be canceled until everything was
fixed but to me the moment that raid was
launched and people saw some of the
encounters it was it was impossible to
hit the reset button yeah yeah so
they're in a tough spot they were in a
tough spot with that i don't know how to
use they could have prepared better but
yeah the uh
to be fair the team that won is one of
the groups that got the most affected by
the connections and they got
disconnected like crazy and they still
want yeah at least there's that lisa's
name so that's all i got i've gone real
bad though you know or
no i will say
our world's first was where we beat the
totals
i was cheering so it's like it's like i
told you travis we spent two hours not
understanding that you it was all in one
thing yeah one thing we were doing we
made it
we made it over complicated for no
reason but look enough about that
possibly look at he fell out the chair
he's asleep
where'd he go
you can't i knew we would do it at 12 so
we got to edit but look i got gotta
shout my bros out on the way out the
last and shout out to the people that
stayed strong for 12 hours that came
through our chat yeah salute senpai
all you guys up in there man i seen you
i was like wow sure capri came through a
lot of people came through to check on
like yo y'all still going that's crazy
but again for me yeah shout out to you
yeah for that
you mentioned yourself shout out to you
for being part of the raid but not being
part of that i'm going to say anything i
i listen i tune in to support look man
but anyway let's just give my shout out
to my brother thank you for pulling up i
know you guys got raining to do
the last word podcast the tr the trinity
now the holy trinity the cheetah tiger e
where can the people find you and uh are
you um doing more raiding tonight
uh for me yeah etsy montes everywhere
twitch twitter youtube
everything all that stuff look at me
bontis you'll find my things uh tonight
after nomad like had tickets for the
batman he's seen at like six so as soon
as he's done and home we're gonna be
jumping on so i'll probably be raiding i
think like nine ish my time so which is
central and we're trying to just finish
so we can get that emblem we're on the
final encounter um and that's kind of
good i know you're going to do it yeah
you got you got a good team you got a
good team bro good luck with that yeah
we can
yeah it's like i got it and plus you're
well arrested yeah you're gonna go in
there i wish i would have responded to
that thread
no doubt shut up gto on twitch he says
one last word during my waking hours he
bought this lobby bonds love put the
cheater size in there salute no doubt
and of course we got my man the other
half of this other thing that we do ty
got travis of the big cats who went
early trav you were beast you went
streaming you did last word with us then
you streamed you did the raid can you do
it to what you call it big time then you
cover iop and you still i'm assuming are
you ready today
i got you i got you i'm definitely
playing destiny today i don't know i
might just wait to do the raid stuff
tomorrow and and today just catch up on
all the end game stuff that unlocked
yeah there's like quests and stuff so
um yeah i don't know yet but uh yeah i
just got off of the big cast show i had
a like hour-long debate with hogue on
games as a service model and whether or
not it's good or bad for the industry
you two are the worst people to be on
one podcast you're gonna argue all the
time
he was fiercely against me and i i just
i could not what was yours what was the
position my position was that games as a
service is just a different way of doing
it and games can be bad or good in both
but then he was arguing that halo
infinite was a bad game because it
launched
half baked and i was just like dude no
it's a game as a service this is how it
works and yeah i just i couldn't get
behind what he's saying but watch it
it's a super interesting debate
pieces of content i've created a long
time you can follow me on twitter guy
travis uh all the stuff i create all the
content i created is on ign.com so you
can read my review and progress of the
witch queen and my life my full review
with the score will probably happen
wednesday i'm thinking at this point
maybe maybe tuesday we'll see no doubt
absolutely and i want to point out
that you could ask call the moment fire
team chat went out
i told cog i was like you someone needs
to reach out to travis i think he'd be
perfect for uh last word it worked out
it worked out yeah yeah it was just like
it was a perfect fit he's a cool guy
yeah we got a chance to play with him
and and halo infinite so uh
and you'll be proud of me
make sure
y'all shout out to the twitter last
world podcast subscriber saying i'm
doing the thing i'm doing the thing
without you yeah see with the viewership
i'm doing it i'm learning see you should
be happy but uh we got one of the best
damn destiny podcasts out here man check
this out generally every thursday 7 p.m
eastern sometimes friday depending on
the guest you know what i'm saying
they're out of control yeah but now
shout out to that man it's at 7 00 p.m
i'm just crawling in better i said i see
him in the morning you gonna get the
most laughs you're gonna bug out you
know i'm saying sometimes be in traffic
go out it'll be funny and then sometimes
travis didn't go out and be funny and we
laugh at e when he don't put condiments
on his food so go check him out
[Laughter]
yo bros you like it bald face thank you
iron laws and for those who talk about
why y'all talk about that listen if it
wasn't for destiny it'd be no iron
lord's podcast this is the fact that
yeah and to be honest with you look
listen
some people don't like when we talk
about nintendo some people don't like
when we talk about destiny all due
respect it's all podcasts we talk about
whatever we make
exactly
exactly yeah
it's like look we do take feedback if
there's a topic you don't like ben
there's time stamps later on don't don't
don't take the sony approach
thank you for sticking through
and pushing through it because we we
love your resiliency
yeah shout out to judo give it bonuses
props for the gtg to stream the charity
e tell the people what you did this week
before you go uh yeah so bungie has its
game to give kind of annual charity
stream marathon that they do and it kind
of got broken in half for kind of an
unfortunate situation last year
uh but i went through and just thanks to
a whole bunch of generous people in chat
a lot of fun
uh shout out to me wearing a full on
woody costume from toy story during the
stream
i tried the bomb sauce for the first
time and i've just absolutely nearly
died
um
and then at some point
i was like and at some point you're
going to get a full cheetah suit
oh yeah so yeah it was 3 800 total
raised my goal was 5 000 but it's still
more than i've ever raised for any
charity stuff that i've done so it was
awesome turnout a lot of fun it ended up
being a good 12 hours so that was that
was tuesday that was a reset so that was
that was an absolute blast so but game
to give that's always i mean it's the
bundy bungee foundation for ipads for
kids for all the kids in hospitals going
through whatever they're going through
usually always for children's hospitals
and then for everything for diversity
and inclusion that they do bungie's very
very good about that and then direct
relief for anything from what ukraine's
going through right now and everything
else like they always have very good
causes that they support so i was very
very happy to be a part of that and
helped contribute no doubt appreciate
you being always doing the right thing
in the community also support my brother
trav ign.com that review is in progress
hopefully maybe tuesday we'll get that
trap i'm looking forward to that and
every wednesday okay cool tuesday
wednesday and hopefully it'll be better
than the downward trend of the review
scores that you've been giving and i
just hope that does not fall lower than
the last score that you gave yeah i mean
to be fair he got saddled with crossfire
x that's nice
i don't think it's a spoiler to say i'm
going to be above a 2. yeah
you know what's funny travis i was in a
party within you was playing that and it
got to the point where it sounded like
the game was becoming kind of enjoyable
how bad it was to him like
that's actually one of the things i said
in my review is like at least you'll
you'll you will laugh like it's
impossible not to it's i looked up
where's er
this week i looked at where zur was i
was like where is there the first thing
that popped up was your ign
we got better videos
his video yeah you got yeah you got to
go to the east one exactly you gotta go
to each video but look brother i've
literally scrolled down
passing people to find ease video on
certain things i'll be like i'll be like
i bet you he has the same video i'm
trying to give the fab this view before
some random stranger
home team
a lot of amazing creators in that
community but always thank you guys last
word podcast love y'all brothers thank
y'all for pulling up solving gonna get
the super chats one of my bros rolls and
then we get stuff yeah all right see you
out thursday
guys thank you
[Music]
um guys yeah i'm gonna get these super
test guys yes and then i have to bounce
oh i'll tell you why okay in a moment
okay yeah no problem we got you we got
you brother um
okay uh hold on let me
i think i got all you got
cool yeah yeah okay so we have
rarest tortoise with the one pound 79
pen super chat pass it on to the charity
of your choice thank you sir his his uh
patreon win will get passed on to
someone else
of course i appreciate that thank you
sir then we have snowball back slap five
dollars super chat oh no we read this
one already
the chat is as disconnected from uh this
conversation
jumped out there and we got uh brian lay
member for two months shout out to hemi
upgraded to lord gold so thank you sir
appreciate that
then we have necromancer zale five
dollar super chat i missed the warlock
solar revival super
okay yeah yeah self rest
yeah you know who would do that
[Laughter]
then we got kate johnson five dollar
super chat studying for work and
listening at the same time not as active
in the chat today but still loving the
show hit that like button fire every
sunday thank you man thank you so much
love much love
then we have donna taco five dollar
super chat took a nice app while not i
guess nap
now let's get on to the real topics joke
destiny's cool just don't have the time
for it no doubt
then we have j mouselin two dollar super
chat cog you played half-life alex yet
it's great yes yes
yeah absolutely amazing
then we have mr irishman 10-pound super
chat appreciate the therapeutic break
this podcast has given me from eldon
ring millennia the blade of mikhail has
been tanning my damn hide for over 12
hours i can't wait for king's live
tanning
oh my lord
like it's not happening and i'm so
pleased like i said i am a prophet
so uh yeah unfortunately my wife just uh
she called me hysterical they broke into
our car they took our registration they
took a bunch of stuff that was in the
car they cracked the back windshield uh
so i gotta go handle that go ahead why
would they need your registration which
is stupid because they can do nothing
with it but it would just they just they
all they do they're looking for stuff
yeah exactly
so uh yeah i gotta go bro
they grabbed a bunch of papers and did
no registration we got don't worry about
it make sure everything my apologies
once again okay do not have the
opportunity to talk about eldon right
now i know every time
you know don't worry don't worry about
it don't worry about talking about elder
ring in your stead yeah don't worry
about another do your thing
my apologies again uh i will talk to you
guys next time brother all right don't
worry about it
thanks guys all right no doubt no doubt
look let's get into it man solves topics
so i'll kind of
frame it for him because a lot going on
ld ring just from a success standpoint
let me put the topic up yeah it's the
biggest shout out to games industry that
business the biggest non-f fifa butcher
that or call of duty launch since red
dead redemption 2 on the uk digital
charts bigger than assassin's creed
valhalla bigger than cyberpunk 2077 and
they said its sales were two and a half
times that of last week's big new
release horizon forbidden west in fact
it's
why you laughing
well in fact it's the biggest game
launch outside of call of duty and fight
fifa franchises since red dead
redemption october it's week one sales
up yeah again i repeated myself uh
bigger than cyberpunk and assassin's
creed valhalla and yeah they just it's
been it's been a monster it's definitely
been a monster so let's talk about it at
it you've been rocking you've been
rolling a little bit what showers yeah
man like you know what's your feeling on
i know we're gonna get into the game but
what's your feeling on the financial
success right now that's coming out
earlier from the uk
um
the uk i think you're gonna see that
everywhere uh i think benji actually
said that it's one of the most trending
games has ever been on steam
so
look
let me think
when it comes to this game
this is one of those standard things
where i will
say that you know those reviews hit
because
when people saw that 97
it didn't matter what type of game it
was it was everyone's type of game
regardless if that's good or bad for the
franchise i never feel like that could
ever be bad for the franchise that
people are buying the game because of
the hype that that 97 generated and the
high people generally are playing it
because i don't think it's all the
reviews i think it's a lot of word of
mouth
but i do think those reviews have
something to do with it when you see a
97 on metacritic especially to a lot of
hardcore gamers that is quality on top
of quality that's not every day people
don't realize how hard it is to score a
97 on anything
that's almost a perfect score
yep
and i i think people saw that and
they're like look man like we gotta jump
in that and
i think you're seeing a lot of people
jump on the game because
one thing the quality of the game
regardless of some of the performance
issues there is a lot of performance
issues people can't deny the amount of
time that was took to make this open
world i do feel like it it could be
better in terms of how they made the
opal war i feel like the lore could have
been explained a little bit more and i
know people are like well that's just a
from software game right um
bloodborne is a from software game and i
feel like they told the world better
there i get it it's a little bit more on
a broader scale i i said it in um
another podcast i just don't like the
the feeling that i walk into random
dungeons yeah and there's just a random
boss there of no real lore behind it you
know what i'm saying like
there are so many times i can fight the
same giant with different color or you
know the same form of giant with
different aesthetic and not think of
what's the point in doing this besides
just xp and money well the xp is the
money but
golden ring is definitely my game of the
year i don't
that being touched by anything
when i saw this the only thing i thought
of is
this is gonna hurt this is gonna hit
um this is gonna hit starfield uh
because
i don't see because i they're both both
they kind of describe starfield as like
a hub world not necessarily open world
but i was that was but that was maybe i
don't know if they they've said well i
don't know maybe you're right maybe you
found some information i don't know i i
didn't know actually i i think the way
it was described as it was like a no
man's sky i don't know we haven't really
got a whole lot of information on that
but regardless how it is
starfield is going to be compared with
it because it's going to be that rpg so
let me ask you this before the
probability wrap for a second
so
you're going a lot of poll questions
[ __ ] people should is the towel thrown
in
like should they
stop the fight like it's
that nobody else could do
give it a year
i don't see it
came out this year i just
i just don't see it like
you know it and i do think you i think
you're right i think i'm getting evolved
and starkville mixed up
but
regardless of that
i just don't see starfield beating it
right i just don't like
i can't really like i don't know because
they've never done a game like star
field so it might be completely
different but
playing bethesda games and playing from
software games
like
eldon ring is on a completely different
level than from software has ever made
and i know slo-mo is like it's it's
march
i get it
but at the end of the day
i don't see
any way possible this game win loses
game of the year like the the amount of
of hype this game's getting and it's not
false generated hype this game is
getting people like kids smooth to
stream it without a challenge mode going
in place again this game is getting
people that i have know are very
adamant about hating these type of games
to buy this this game got king to play
it right
it's just like look like i know kings
played sakura but a lot of people that
don't normally like this type of
gameplay they're willing to try it
and when you play this game you play the
open world about it you you see the
different biomes you you just becoming a
ross and a foggy air bam there's a boss
you'd be killing people bam there's a
ball it's like it's done a really good
job like look there's a lot of things
that comes in
that they do a good job of storytelling
but there isn't a lot of situations that
you're playing it that's like
man this is good this is one of the few
games that i'm
not even probably halfway through the
game and i'm already like yo i need a i
need to do another playthrough
and i just remembered it when addicts
said it right now
something terrible happened to me
i'm you know going through the world
and i see a little area over there where
some zombies is over there some little
dirty little dogs
over there and i kill them right
then i climb over the rocks and i'm like
right and i see these four no these
three little um like uh like crystals
in the ground
i'm picking those up
somebody love crystals you see who left
these out here like this and then i seen
like a couple of little zombie dudes
over there so i walk over there and then
it goes
like
how about this great dragon has shown
up yo the biggest monster the
dragon just swoops in sets me on fire
you have died and i'm like what like
what's going on he didn't give me a
chance to just to suit up get ready
nothing and you know what you should
have did king you should have watched
that uh you should have read that
the tips for beginners that uh that we
have up on the iron let's do it the
lords of gaming.net
no we we do have i literally have in
that it says
don't fight the dragon
like so i didn't fight the dragon i was
busy touching crystals right so my
ignorance like i i go around if i see
blood on the floor i go
this is where somebody has met the
unfortunate demise
and i look at it and then i see stupid
things that people do like fall off a
cliff
i said thank you fool thank you fool for
showing me what not to do
there was no blood in that area for the
dragon
i just saw the crystals so i don't care
i'm i'm i'm thinking about uh financial
freedom
i said i want to be able when the shop
pop up when i catch a dude that's
selling something i like i want to slide
up on them with these crystals i'm like
yo how much these issues could get me
what's up with this how much these
crystals work for all here so i found
these crystals over here and i think
they're nice and the dragon was like
those my crystals put those down
[Laughter]
stop that
what you doing over there touching
okay i think the thing that makes this
game so unique
is just
the sense of freedom that you could go
anywhere you want you could do anything
you're not sure some place you can go
there's gonna be more beef than other
places
and some place you could go you can
gonna get one shot for probably another
20-30 hours well you could go there if
you want i don't know
i saw
i'm i'm walking down the hill
i see this golden dude riding a horse
with a spear yeah the the tree sentinel
once again in my review uh in the tips
that we put out we said stay away from
him
you don't gotta tell me it's not
curiosity doesn't
does not hit me in that manner i saw him
patrolling the area i said oh he looks
like he's ready to kill people
it looks real savage out here i said
that is not an area what i will be
exploring
and i decided to go mess with you you
know what's funny
you get to a point in the game where you
start fighting two of him at a time see
this is the dumbest part about it
because
literally
the only help you have is the death of
others right
what has befell calvin in this situation
what did calvin do wrong here we're
gonna go left for him yo [ __ ] you walk
up to a joint
and you like yeah let me see this i
think i think that's ingenious
and you you click on it and you they say
press y to read right so like read
do you see some guy like no please oh
god
are you like what the hell is no please
oh god
what happened here and you step forward
and you are doing the same exact
animation oh please so good
because it's literally
you are walking around this world
trying not to do what the blood did on
the floor this is this is what the whole
thing is the whole thing is avoid
becoming a blood splatter to somebody
else or somebody else
yeah because
the whole thing is because you're going
to see it
and you're going to be like oh what's
this on the floor no those are deaths of
individual and that's all over the place
right so that means
thousands of people have done the same
thing and thousands of people are dead
to warn you not to do the same so it
becomes a game of cat and mouse
how can i avoid becoming a a
a martyr for the next dude how can i
avoid uh becoming a a warning a
forebearing of what's to come and it's
little things that will kill you because
you don't really know the dude's story
you don't know that he fought something
over here and he was low on energy and a
bat bit him right you don't know that
right but you just see the bat bite him
and then it'll be some stupid some
stupid little warning and i don't know
how to write them yet because i'm gonna
write mean stuff but
that's the entire from sophomore
community bunch of toxic stuff i don't
even read that stuff because i don't
know
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i don't know about this
you can write notes to other people and
they'll troll you like they'll put it on
top of a legend from software is like
famous for putting hidden areas in games
okay and they'll put they'll put hidden
area jump off ledge on the hair oh yeah
so you think oh there's something nice
down here and you jump and die
no lie
i was so pissed off because some dude
put secret area here
there's no secret area so i stood there
for a good 20 minutes trying to figure
this out like i gotta get a secret area
okay you know what's funny
with one of the bosses and someone
invaded us
got kind of like what you were saying
last week that's when i went so the
moment i saw that red title pop up and i
said he was a samurai i was like the
first thing i said smooth let's jump him
so let's jump him let's get him
did y'all kill him
oh yeah we killed him he was up out of
there like i was funny you smooth just
sat there and watched and i killed him
but you know
this that's my only quest in this game
to get strong enough that i can go and
terrorize everybody that's playing this
game like so when you're playing and
you're just like oh let me go over here
to this dungeon king david has entered
your world
and i'm just saying that because i'm a
warrior
i fell listen and i'ma feel like ghost
rider riding on my horse coming and
slashing your head off i just cannot
wait to be that strong so i could do
that malicious stuff and that's all i
want to do with this game i'm just going
to invade constantly and do
terrorizations and i want people to post
them like king david killed me here
listen
was making fun of uh me and smooth
because we was fighting the first boss i
was hoping smooth and
i got tired of smooth dying because if
the host dies you have to go back
so i saw smooth got hit a couple times i
knew he had no more potions i was like
get behind me don't go in front of him
anymore get behind me let him let me
finish it
listen man we gotta we gotta shut up my
boy pulled up last minute to hold us
down assistant editor-in-chief lords of
gaming.net's
own nicholas downey salute let me check
your level sir make sure you sounding
okay
what's going on guys i'm a little
gravely but bear with me i appreciate
that canada in the building salute i'm
saying and also gaming perspective
podcast man cheat code radio doing man
doing it all you know what i'm saying
but look i i i thought you were perfect
for this topic because
one i didn't want to get your analytical
sense of
elder rings massive success right now i
mean that we're seeing
and then the second part is i didn't
know
you were like me
and you were not really a souls guy that
surprised me so to see you comment
really resonated with me there's a
couple people that i know that are it's
like it's like this red cult against the
world that everyone else is like with
something and then like we're like not
that we're against it we just didn't
participate and then when i seen you you
played i'm like oh yo
on dad's enjoying it so let's talk about
it the first part the success
second part
how are you feeling about it
all right all right you know it's a good
sunday because king's eating pineapple
the man knows man is a man of culture
this game is insane like the this game's
metrics are off the charts like this is
number one on mpd no cap easy peasy
nothing else is touching it
um
like this game is like they're saying pc
sales they're estimating anywhere
between like five to ten million pc
sales alone
um the game broke its concurrent player
record today it had 986 000 people
playing concur a week later and that's
like wow
a week later on a single player game so
like
wow yeah it's gonna be like a 20 30
million uh 20 30 million unit cell game
oh easily like this this will be the
best this will like triple the last from
soft game easily because i think sakura
was like
what five six million in a couple of
months or something like that yeah
something crazy like that man yeah so
like this this one's good this one's
doing numbers and i think it's because
they did such a different like it's
still a souls game like don't get me
wrong like this game is incredible it
can be incredibly frustrating but i i
don't know the game clicked with me this
time like i got it only because my game
share partner
got it and then he auto downloaded to my
console he's like oh by the way i helped
you out i downloaded for you i was like
man
[Laughter]
and i was like oh well you know if you
don't if you don't try it do you really
know if you don't like it
and let's go i i've i've found the
comedy in this game now like and before
i try to play souls games i always get
so frustrated because i felt like i was
smashing my head off a wall repeatedly
because you get to one boss and like i'm
not good at these games so i'm just like
oh my god i've just hit my head off a
wall repeatedly like i'd rather do that
than play some of these games
but
the just the sheer absurdity of this
game gets to you after a time i was
fighting a boss and we're like we're
duking it out and everything's going
well and then all of a sudden this goat
comes rolling down
and smacks me in the butt it only does
like 20 damage but i'm like look the
wildlife is rolling and attacking me now
i'm trying to fight this job
like
there's just so many moments because of
the way the world's designed
you have so many
more interesting moments within the game
like i had a really stupid moment like i
look back on it was stupid because my
curiosity got the better of me
this stone circle in the middle of a
field that's glowing purple and i'm like
what's that
look i'm like interactive and it
teleports into a boss fight it didn't
even teleport me it was like i just i
interact with it all of a sudden this
purple wall comes up around here
yeah that that it teleports you to that
wall oh no okay
yeah and uh yeah all of a sudden it's
like health bar appears big black knight
comes up i'm like all right let's square
up let's let's go what's good he smacks
he smacks me once i instantly die
yes yes
what's funny is um
i went up on top of like this this area
i just had a random a boss shows up i'm
okay so i get him halfway his health
like all he really does is like he has
like a double
staff and he just swings it around like
he'll come at you you have very
predictable abilities and then and then
he becomes mr incredible and starts like
stretching his body and then he'll put
like half his body and then swing the
rest of his body around it and i'm like
i'm like i'm just sitting here like this
is ridiculous like they really ran out
of ideas with this dude like
and so and some of the enemies are just
straight up disrespectful like i was
sitting there minding my own business
beating up some peasants
all of a sudden this bear that's like
three or thirty feet tall jumps off the
cliff and just smacks me into the ground
and proceeds to just keep smacking me
into the ground and i'm they're very
aggressive they're chasing out of their
biome what
like ads are very like dedicated like
they won't leave a certain area but that
bear has chased me for a minute before
like that and i and what's funny is i'm
like level 100 and something
and i won't fight that bear because even
that even to this day
if i see a bear show like i remember i
needed
i i looked for like 30 minutes on like
because there's a way you can reset your
attributes and everything but you need a
certain item and i'm like and i get i
gave up let me look up where this damn
item is so i look up online and the
first one that popped up was you have to
kill one of those bears for it i'm like
damn i gotta fight one of those bears
so so i walked up to that bear and i'm
like hey mr bear
do we gotta fight do we gotta go through
it
[Laughter]
but i think for me
you know
it's it's really big to see and i think
saul wanted to express this like
the the casual right that the guy like
me who who's not into souls like that or
respects it who understands what it
knows it's a great game and i'm trying
to disrespect it it's just i knew for me
that's not the type of game that i would
get into it to see
you know king to see
so many people that i know would
normally not play this game and then
when i speak to maddie on defining duke
and he's like yo the skyrim like a genre
yeah it's it's
this is what i want to know
and and the unfortunate uh bearer of the
brunt of this financial windfall
for elden ring is for rise horizon
forbidden west yeah right they they
i want to know how many people
took their money
and said
this or that
this he's gonna bring up horizon in this
yeah we know how rob's going to come in
something and
then it's like of course they're going
to get this work i mean
at some point in time you know um poor
choice in in launching
uh
it's going to
uh we go it's ugly head no one could
have predicted this is the second time
they run up to a game of the year
damn they're shuring
and
it's the thing
i will
like defend horizon and gorilla and sony
just a little bit is
i think people
knew that elder ring was going to come
in good but i don't think people
expected this but
i feel like eldon ring
people's generally gravitated towards
from software games and they've enjoyed
it and they've usually revealed well but
this is the first time front soccer has
delivered a game that i felt was like
gaming wise
evolved the frank like the world like
like no one it's so bad right now i'm
being told by by youtubers not to make
videos because eldon ring is so dominant
on youtube that if you're not making
elder ring videos and you don't have a
huge following don't even try
my thing with that is is this
um
you you see the game and and you
understand and i'm not i'm not i'm not
taking anything away from what they did
and what they accomplished
you guys were head over heels for this
thing for the last four years
y'all built up weirdos
the hype level was there yeah yeah you
don't remember cog winner they was like
yeah elder ring is coming are you going
to play i'm like oh no
but that like up until those reviews
dropped that hype was there for sakura
the hype was there for demons slow even
though that that wasn't made by from
software i get what you're saying
i think people expected this to be a
good from software game and their hype
for that i don't think people expected
what we actually got okay so let me give
you the difference with what i've
learned really quickly between secreto
uh bloodborne and this
those games are linear
right those games are really as a set
path for maybe you can veer off into one
little space over here and take around
the board and go this way this game
really just pops you and be like do you
yeah and i i think the
new aspect of it is actually where it's
winning it's it's like you're not going
to die as much or you it doesn't seem
like you're going to die as much because
you are you literally can avoid certain
circumstances there's certain
circumstances in bloodborne you just
can't avoid like you really have to do
this one part to get to this one part to
get to this next part and then you can
branch over to this other part this
joint
i may never see something that you saw
me my curiosity i came out the tomb and
i walked to the back of the house
like i want to know how many people walk
to the back of the house oh i can tell
you five
i'll get five splatters i i i definitely
agree with you
but what i saw going into this because i
was keeping up with the hype is i saw
people excited for her from software
games but people were still skeptical of
an open world let's be real everything's
open world there's a little huge open
world for deep i don't think people was
really thinking it would be like to this
level that's really good
i'm gonna give it back to to um to nick
in the sense that like
to to addict's point i do feel
once the reviews came in
that
curiosity even further it'll be like yo
what's going on like you know over 97 or
whatever what a credit open critic and
then can combine that you know with the
fact to king's point that i remember you
know the keegley a reveal was a big deal
you know what i'm saying i remember like
i remember when it was first oh you know
the elderly like soul fans were going
crazy and they didn't on top of it to
see so i want to give it back to nick to
finish this point and then we got slo-mo
and building salute for pulling up but
um yeah i think what what's your thought
process on that aspect with the hype and
the expectation and it meeting it and
what do you feel what the fact is there
well i think
part of the thing that like from
software games are an event for that
community and i agree with you i think
the reviews of this game definitely
drove uh a lot more people to it um and
the things that interested me in the
reviews is i automatically discounted
about 50 of the reviews because a lot of
sites used there from software fans
and i'm like oh look the same group that
can overlook just about anything that's
wrong in these games is saying it's a 10
out of 10. but it was interesting to
watch people who traditionally didn't
like these games going hey
this is the game that is exciting yes
right now yes and i think why alden ring
is standing out so
so well not only in terms of it being a
souls game
is it stands out really well because in
comparison to the other open world games
uh it had it's more a traditional old
school you know you're you're
discovering and exploring things horizon
dying like two i've played both of those
games extensively those very much are
you know modern
here's your waypoint go right here do
this do that you know
your traditional checklist
with eldon ring you you don't know what
you're doing you you're just like i'm
going this way and i'm going to see
what's over here right and if it one
hits me i know i need to go different
i can't really agree on that because
there's been huge successful open worlds
like the greatest like the witchers the
the skyrims the elder scrolls in general
uh to degree fallouts they have waypoint
system like i'm not saying this is like
a good open world immersive game is
going to be good regardless if they tell
you where to go or not yeah but to my
point the reason why people love this
world so much is all the games you named
are from five years ago we haven't moved
on from those games and that game design
because more and more people as much as
people like to dunk on ubisoft
almost everyone designs their open world
games like ubisoft games yep 2012. yep
and what makes elden rings so
interesting is it's like that it's not
like that at all it's like your old
school 1990s rpg where you're dumped
somewhere and you're like okay well i
guess i'm going in this direction right
yeah and
and it's not objective objective
objective objective go here uh do this
uh gold
it's literally
you go to spaces to clear out the map to
find out the is this so much exploring
it's something i like that i do like
that i see now you're selling me because
that
i didn't i didn't know that aspect about
it but that's the reason why even though
and even what school has a little bit of
weight points but that was the reason
why go sushima really resonated with me
because exploring i know that motif
everybody's like you're the ninja girl
you're the same of course but it was the
exploration it was okay where is the
wind because what's going on here and
then okay what's going on oh there's a
temple there's a shrine up there let me
see what's in the background and the
vibe i'm getting from all of you
is that
the game is not holding your hand on top
of the fact with the difficulty which is
which is it it says its own little cool
thing that they it's that difficult in
an open world setting but like just the
wonder of anything can happen and you go
explore like so nick is that
because for you to me you represent me
and i'm gonna give it back to you guys i
just gotta ask this question like
you know as a person don't really take
to these games like that so to hit like
was that what was the moment where you
go yo
i mean
what what was it without the ring
the the moment for me that's kind of
secured me into elden ring is what i
like is like so my first one i tried to
do the first story boss right off the
bat that's where i found myself going
and i bounced super hard off of him i
was like ooh that was rough i need to do
something else and what elderly ring
allowed me to do is i went i killed
another boss i did a couple of sub
bosses i found some weird bosses that
aren't part of the story at all but you
can go kill them get runes upgrade
yourself and i had like this great
little journey for like 15 hours
exploring this world finding little
caves doing some dungeons and everything
else and then i looped back around and
did that first boss again
and i nailed it second try
and i'm like this is dope because it's
like the game's not telling you oh you
have to go do that because there's tons
of people that can cakewalk through
these bosses right you know first try
they're way better than i am but for me
as a player since i'm not that good
there is an option for me to explore and
still do interesting and meaningful
content to get better and i really enjoy
that aspect of eldon ray it makes me not
as fearful of the difficulty because i
know
there's other things i can go do i can
go kill cave giants for half an hour if
i want to to get more runes to level up
and then go face the boss i'm having
trouble with i just think they've done a
really great job
of
varying the content so everything feels
so incredibly unique and open no doubt
king and attic you're gonna finish not
giving up the slope you remember how we
felt when we got kings failed yes
yes
oh oh so this is that
this is that okay now you got me because
i know exactly what you mean this this
is that this is
you go in a a different uh cave you go
into a different space
and it's in exploring right we cleared
out the map we we we learn things we
it's so much exploration
to play it yeah how you choose to
uh explore it and and me coming from a
real standpoint of ignorance like
because i'm absolutely ignorant when it
comes to uh from software games
um
that i'm like okay
this reminds me of dragon's dogma i love
dragon's dogma right i love dragon's dog
dragon's dogma is so dope for me i just
finished buying it again for my son you
know uh so he could play it you know
they had a sale on it and i'm like this
what it reminds me of
and you're going through the world and
you're checking out stuff and you look
so i look off a cliff
and i saw some bats
like flying and they're huge bats
they're not little bats right they're
huge bat people right and they're down
there flying
and i said and you you get that question
to yourself can you take them
and i said i said yeah
right so i said okay so how am i gonna
get down there so i'm looking how to get
down there you see a blood splatter and
if you fell off the cliff this way okay
i'm not gonna go that way i'ma climb
down this way and i came down and i read
one little sign that dude says time you
jump swings
somebody vibe
people can leave helpful stuff there
they can leave toxic stuff there right
and what's funny is if someone likes
your helpful stuff that heals you in the
game yeah so you could you could you
could be fighting
you gave a helpful uh advice that
someone liked in the actual menu when
they brought up your menu it will heal
you so you could be on the brink of
death and that and get a random message
can get you healed and keep in mind a
hill in any from software game is huge
it doesn't matter how much oh absolutely
not that you got to save me now cause um
i like this i like i love it i love
hating so what about
the failing right because you gonna die
in this game clearly right so you're not
upset with it okay so that's what i say
like so for king that's the key question
like when you die
they just wipe you off your stuff like
how are they doing you on the desk so
let me be honest yeah i told you before
these dudes played hours and hours right
i know you that's why i'm coming to you
i only only played probably an hour or
so into it because i was doing other
things right like i'm helping people do
this stuff with that so whatever so
when i died i really didn't get a chance
to look at my inventory it just asked me
if i want to spawn from the place that i
was experiencing from or the last place
here so i was like no i was spawning in
the last place outside i'm gonna get
back at these dogs right so
and i noticed this time that i don't
attack the dogs in the same manner i
didn't get a chance to check my stuff to
see how much money i lost or whatever i
lost because i really
didn't care because i knew it was my
mistake not for you right so now i know
okay so i lock in and i'm using like
attic asks me
so how are you doing are you doing dual
welding i said nah
i'm doing the shield
and i'm doing the sword
so the dog try to you know jump at me
because i'm not good at timing my rolls
right so i think the dudes that do
double swords are great at timing their
roles
yeah i have double swords and smooth has
a big shell yeah yeah
i was watching he don't you know parrot
he he he's off the roll the dodge timing
yeah
how i've always considered these games
is like dodging mechanics in these type
of games regardless of from software or
not
pairing is always like
up in the air if it works correctly if
it doesn't work correctly
i don't risk learning it in any other
game the only game i actually had to
learn it was was sacro and i was
hard-headed it took me halfway through
the game before i learned tonight so
because that game demands it if you
don't learn how to parry you won't beat
sakura
well i mean i guess you can if you beast
and you never get hit but
this
this game is one of the things where i'm
playing with smooth and smooth has a big
great shield and i'm dodging i get hit
one time half my health is gone smooth
puts up that shield the dude would
literally take anything the boss throws
at him like get hit over this game had
me on a boss where i was so infuriated
i'm like where's that dragon grace
shield i'm about to put that sucker on
like and i literally was tanking because
i i
felt like there was no other way of me
beating that boss dodging his crazy
patterns okay fair enough slow mo slow
backslash we'll make sure he's level you
keep jumping and jumping out make sure
you're good
slow uh-oh slow might be having
technical difficulties so hopefully we
get them a little later but uh
yeah update zoom brother make sure you
run the latest client and sometimes
that'd be the issue can you hear me yeah
there you go there we go slow right
finally finally i've been i've been
fighting zoom for the past five minutes
i saw that you brought you zoom almost
as bad as some of these elder ring balls
oh
man
i'm damn bad out here
i appreciate the invite
look man talk to me so much fun with
this game talk to me now you're a souls
god sloth no i'm not not at all see i
need to hear this months ago okay six
months ago i was like man
yeah
catch me playing the souls game never
right like you like me
brought up the receipt slow-mo i know
someone's done that by now oh yeah look
look a lot of people have been giving me
crap about this because look i think it
was a shout out to t-rock t-roc
um on on my strings
he's always in on my streams i really
appreciate the brother i i got like a
lot of people always like so we want you
to play this game and i'm like i don't
want to play that
it is fun when you don't want to play
something yeah like it's fun you're a
great streamer because you yeah okay
sorry i can't i can't it's just like i'm
just like like i have the worst time but
people love my misery so they're just
like yes
they're like we want you to play souls
games all right i'm gonna set up channel
points i made it as high as i possibly
could 50 000 the same way when i was
made to play those retro games
right right
so glad that part of my life is over
i can do it i will never do that ever
look at his face is disgusting
t rock actually collected 50 000 channel
points and chose demon souls remake so i
had to play it
the whole time i'm like man i'm about to
get body left and right people going
but like i did get body lifter right but
i did enjoy i had fun actually you know
i had a nice little build you know half
melee half magic i was having fun and so
like i realized it's like although it is
a bit i think i still think the game
combat does have a bit of jank to it
okay that it is fun and i think the the
the difficulty comes in from software
not
doing things that other developers do
for games they don't tell you how to do
this
like in in the elder ring i had no idea
how to
how to hold the weapon with two hands um
i had to i i'm trying to figure it out i
had to look it up how to just hold a big
weapon with two hands and
like that wasn't something that was
explicitly said so i feel like i feel
like that's kind of cap though slow-mo
oh boy wow
learning the basic
basic controls of a game i feel like is
never something that any developer
shouldn't be okay with doing like the
fact that you that that's kind of bad
like you should be at least be told the
basic controls of how to talk about all
the devs oh
yeah
although she's a capitalist oh i'm like
i can't know i can understand a little
bit on like not putting icons and stuff
on the map i think that's kind of
far-fetched too but like
we can't praise them because they didn't
teach us how to deal with it
i'm not praising them for that i'm just
saying that like i i think that's part
of the difficulty is that like you know
oh yeah how do you do certain things and
the fact that literally anything can to
tap you you'd be out of here yeah yeah
billy goat come around and slap you
upside the head yeah you know you did
you
[Music]
it's the unpredictable nature of the
game
and then you can see if if given time
and patience
you can get good mm-hmm you know some
people can become great
but
given the time you put into it you can
you you're going to love it i'm i'm i'm
honestly going to tell you because the
technical aspects of it to me
is more forbidding
than anything else with the game not the
difficulty not anything else like that
and if patches do come out and it gets a
whole lot smoother on on certain things
i'm great with it um i just feel like
from a visual standpoint and yeah you
playstation dude it's gonna be like yo
play it on the playstation 5 and play
the playstation 4 version
i'm going to tell you
that's idiotic
um
because the playstation 5 version should
be running better than the playstation 4
version and the same thing with the
series x and as uh those versions should
be running better but again
that's a whole different fight for a
whole different day but you know um but
this is not a game
see and now i was playing cyberpunk
2077. oh yeah right and i told you i
wasn't going to play that until it just
came out right
right
the game just released it was dope
um
new release game fantastic i think y'all
heard of it um
but that game i was willing to wait for
this game
and it has nothing to do with the meta
score it had everything to do with attic
playing it yeah it was following i've
seen it had it played
i've seen him get butt naked and demon
souls and play demon souls not butt
naked in real life yeah i'm like
where are we going with this
okay it's just that type of lord's
podcast
there is a story behind that like the
reason i have to like
strip down in that oh
i i told you i don't like blocking and
people are getting onto me they're like
you got to use your shield like nah i'll
just take off this chest piece before i
start using the shield because it was
giving me a slower roll so i couldn't
out i couldn't dodge anything
yeah
i don't fat wrong games it don't happen
no it doesn't i'd rather go butt ass
naked before i fat roll on any problem
the true hard mode done
done with you
pause
he and i seen him play that game i've
seen him play other games
but this one was a little bit different
right i mean literally a little bit
different in how he attacked the game
and how the game opened up and that
peaked my curiosity and you really can't
escape it you really can't escape elder
ring if you go online if you go on
twitter you really can't escape these
things and it turns into not even just a
fomo situation
it turns into a more of a curiosity
situation right and the fact that you do
give into your curiosity to it you're
rewarded with it because if you come
from the old school where we had to
explore to actually uh uh um to learn
the game and you actually had to have
some form of skill or you built skill up
like playing act razer and stuff like
that this game brings back and it
hearkens back to the old games of ease
learning
of the map when i would pick up a game
and don't know the language and learn
the game like i didn't know that you
could take the shield off i didn't even
know i had a shield on me to be honest
with you i started off with two swords
but then i i pressed down on the button
and i said oh snap i got a shell
i don't even have to do this yeah and
then i i learned how to lock in so like
slow-mo was saying
they don't tell you certain things and
you find it out but then there's a
wonderment to it and then you become
attached to it because you felt that you
accomplished something small but it's
great because it helps you along in the
game yeah that's that's for me well i
wanted to if let's go finish it i want
to ask him two questions in reference to
first continuing starts with the what
you know this person is a nonsense
person yeah i i think um i think that
the exploration in the game and the
vastness of it i literally just
discovered before i got on i got along
with you guys the underground area and i
discovered it by accident i was actually
looking for because i have i have four
different characters look i'm the kind
of guy that like when i and when i get
into like building a character and being
able to like level stuff up and grind
like i get really invested so i've
created four characters i got two melee
focus characters one is the dex build
dual wielding i got another one that's a
a big tank with a massive sword and big
armor um and then i got two magic builds
one's a prisoner and the other one is
astrologer right so like i'm looking for
stuff like gear for my my magic builds i
look up where there is a uh uh
a particular staff that could be better
than my current staff right i just
lucked into the underground area i'm
like oh what's this temple okay hit a
button oh wow where am i going what is
that the temple beside that big tree yes
and i'm just like oh wow i didn't know
any of this was here and it's just like
it's that kind of stuff that really like
if you were there's mad bosses down
there oh yeah yes yeah i i basically
just got on my horse and was just kind
of exploring
this is nice i'm not stopping anywhere
near you because you're gonna once at me
but like you know it looked cool without
my like this is the great stuff that's
that's awesome about it but i don't i do
kind of feel like when i look at that
the the platform with the most reviews
has only like 53 reviews i do think
there's a bit of a like the medicare
score is what it is right
it's it's deserving of all of its
accolades that's going to get it's going
to see later on the year with the awards
and whatnot
but i do think it's a little
there's a little bit of uh
but it's from software so we're just
going to let it slide kind of stuff like
the fact that as king said like this
game isn't running at 60 frames per
second on any platform
it'll be on pc with a 30-90 yeah and a
freaking nuclear reactor
and you still can't get 60 fps in this
game
the fact that it's so convoluted to do
co-op i mean
oh see there we go now these are the
best let's just turn
yeah right but look this is what it is
right so let's say you me and you want a
co-op right so you're like all right
slow i want you to join my world help me
with some stuff
let's do it plus for me when we kill
bosses i get like these rune arcs that i
can um use to upgrade my stats so it's a
benefit to me too great
so i tell you
cod
go make a severed finger
okay make a severed finger okay you
don't make it you use it to draw a sign
well i mean you still have to you have
to create it well you can find some but
like yeah you have to either find some
or you have to create it in the item
creation i need to do this every time we
try to play every single time so then i
gotta go craft an item to play with you
yes every single time and so we have to
go to
the same gray spot right the same area
i'm gonna put my sign down you're gonna
take that finger and wave it in the air
like i just don't care
i'm dead i'm like sure it's the
animation of you waving a finger right
so you're gonna wave the finger
but then also you have to go to the uh
multiplayer area the the matchmaking
area you have to put in the same
password
wait we doing here switch codes we yes
yes and so nobody ain't telling me this
okay so like luca told me her pass code
which was thoughts and all i heard was
thought and so i didn't put the s so we
tried to figure out for about 15 minutes
what the problem was turned out i didn't
have that
ready
for you so we gotta do all that then you
gotta wave the finger in there you gotta
wait hey guys here's my social security
let's go
and i got to be at this bus stop at this
time okay
what that's right
oh
my god
then you go to the symbol say yes you
can join my world and then now now
you could we could play together but
only in the region that we were in the
like race was at so let's say if the
region was was uh
um caleb we can't leave caleb and go to
lim
lim whatever wow we have to stay within
that region question as soon as i
or as soon as you be the boss
i leave the world so do we gotta do the
whole process over again what
yes all right hold on so you mean to
tell me even we did all this the social
security's the bus stop meet me on canal
street at this time with the finger at
this day now we do this
you mean to tell me from that point on
we just can't go through the game
together the entire and just let's say
we just go they don't want you shocking
the game but why have co-op
oh this is uh oh this is this is this is
this isn't demerits this is a big debate
for me now you're happy
how's the process where you jump inside
and beat somebody else
how's that process
what's up i give you that billy
inconvenience that thing but i don't
know so we can't do so we're limited all
right so the world can you go to any
world like any province and then
initiate the co-op or you could only do
okay so you can go there's a bus stop
and everywhere anywhere like there are
grace points all over the place okay so
then there's like these little statues a
lot near a lot of grace points you have
to like activate the summoning statue
and everything to make sure like i think
that's necessary i'm not quite certain
that i think it's necessary who knows
right right but like if you die i leave
uh if i die i leave and then we have to
do the process
don't die no no stick around
there's more there's more
when i join your world i have half the
health and damage that i had in my world
hey you ain't coming in there yeah well
i can understand that from a balance
stamp i'll be nice
i can understand you have half the
potions too
so
for instance let's say i have
stuff coming out now
let's say that i have one
magic potion fba potion when you go into
a world you don't have one you have zero
so
so let's say i have ten health potions
when i join like slo-mo's world i have
five
so
and i do i do agree on standpoints of
keeping stuff balanced but like at the
end of the day like i really don't like
here's the thing like people tell me the
the first software community is crazy
man when i bring up you know i want more
lore and stuff they're like yeah that's
how we watch the game shut up
i want a simple invite system that's how
all from software games shut up
just because i want the franchise to
evolve and be more simplistic in certain
ways but still maintaining the from
software formula because people acting
like i could just click invite from
party to the game that's going to change
[ __ ] somehow wow
it's just it's just it's just
frustrating that when like because i
said that i want like i said look
elden ring is
fine the way it is but i said i would
appreciate more lore more anticipation
into fighting some of these random
trolls that's in cash
i don't want dialogue i don't want this
i'm like
no one's like first off we get a
nintendo switch situation sorry if the
dialogue is done correctly and it's done
efficiently it doesn't matter how it's
done it's still going to be good right
and people bring it up like horizon
because there's a bunch of dialogue or
or monster hunter for that is i'm like
that's an example of too much dialogue
no one said they wanted that like
wow all right good to see you sorry i
got my final questions to y'all get a
chance i like the aspect that you don't
get a chance to big brother the
situation so you got your social
security fighters
big brother
it's not king
that's fine like i understand that like
i'm cool with the fact that like the
person you bring in isn't as strong yeah
i don't have a problem with that
it's just that like why can't i just
pull up a menu yeah i got friends yes
hey cogs online yes how much do you
really want to play with that friend
come on king stop this 20 22
switch
what's funny
what's funny is that do you do you love
your friends so much that you craft a
finger
well what's funny is those scale those
no
let's say i joined kids kids world okay
they'll scale me down
but then they'll scale the world up
because they're stupid stupid people
yeah
so all right let's get into it let's get
into this this is funny all right last
question so obviously you know we're
seeing a success we are seeing like
again early uk reports the digital sales
everything's good everything's sounding
good and then you know we say the
casuals are getting into it critically
acclaimed it's just it's just massive
regardless how i feel about this call
but
the question got to bring it back to
nick and everybody else
is it
over can we
give it a year can we just call it
right now from what we're seeing what we
played
does anything has a chance to dethrone
elder ring from game of the year because
the the streets are talking
about
the streets are talking nick they're
saying stop the fight
don't even show up
breath of the wild starfield whoever you
are
it's over
nick what's your thoughts
uh
look
last time a game that came out in
february one game of the year
it's called elden ring i'm sorry
recently bias is a son of a gun okay
and by you know
the only people are going to be talking
about this game still are the same nerds
that are going to put 5000 hours into
this game
and and you know
yeah
so
tell me the last time a game this
quality came out in february
all right
batman threes not just quality of you
well the bad thing was good though it
wasn't breath of the wild
breath of the wild breath of the wild
a game that's in february doesn't get it
when we don't get quality games like
this in february for the most part games
of this high quality they usually try to
release in november to october for those
for those holiday sales all right
continue let me get that next question
so the thing is
is i'm not going to sit here and pretend
like i know what the rest of the year is
going to look like
and think that nothing can compare to
this
because you know it's a great game
an amazing game
even
you gotta throw to even though
but
but
at the end of the day
the casuals who are going to fall off of
this game in the first three hours
are going to vote for this game to be
game of the year
and at the end of the day i think
there's going to be other games that
come out this year there's games that
are coming up this year that we don't
even know about yet
and i think those those games have just
as much of a start to get it as anybody
else
but
what i will say don't worry attic i got
you that's got to get slower alden ring
does take game of the year
it's an interesting direction
so to speak especially after sakiro is
that they've done back-to-back game of
the years
because sakira took game of the year as
well did elven ring takes game of the
year as well the amount of pressure on
their next game is going to be
astronomical oh yeah definitely they're
not letting me go to the next prize
there's no pressure there's no pressure
in the next game as long as they keep
within the same gameplay loop in the
same game designer they currently do i
don't i don't agree with that i feel
like this game is going to be hard to
beat i'm going to tell you why because
from software now has a seat at the
round table
of free passes
[Music]
you don't have to evolve your game play
for you to still get tens if people when
you don't have you have to have your
game running well that launch for people
to acts like that's the case from
software even though the same the same
reviewer didn't give that same uh out
that same pass the slow clap and seafood
we already at that point were from
software where they're at that table and
they can do what they want
they can they could they could come out
with another game that's another
basically dark souls 3 and people would
be like hey but it's from soft yeah this
is the same hey i i like waving my
finger in there
like like like that's how it works now
when it comes to i still don't think
that they're definitely going to get
game of the year because uh your
question was what other game this early
has come out that has been like of that
high quality i'll say monster hunter
world came out in january
in 2018
amazing high quality was a game of the
year nominee but didn't win um i think
when you got you got god of war ragnarok
you got potentially breath of the wild
too you got starfield
but that's the has been a member at the
table of free passes before too
there we go we also have they're they're
shot as well i think there is a ton of
uh definitely much better than last year
where there wasn't a lot of star power
games coming out there's a ton of high
profile games coming out this year that
are
uh just as uh beloved from developers
that are just as beloved as from
software and i think that they're gonna
have some competition they're not saying
they're not going to win but i think i
don't think it's a slam dunk all right
addict this is your chance to rebut and
you are up
is it over don't stop the fight i don't
think
i don't think
i don't really see people saying stop
the fight oh i'm seeing
i'm not saying stop the fight i'm saying
if you're going to show up you better be
in the best shape of your life
because
i don't think god of war is coming out
this year
i i don't think breath of the wild is
coming out this year if breath of the
wild shows up maybe on that exactly not
to break that laws giving down that
exclusive guy
you know to addict's point i
i'm truly on the boat with both of those
titles being 2023
sorry breath of the wild extensively
because it's got it's got to win the
most anticipated gay upcoming game from
the game awards for like the third year
in a row um
but yeah i don't see either of those
games god of war was coming out this
year we wouldn't we would know a release
date by now i mean we we we in
march
about the middle of march already like
the they we would know it's exactly like
i said last year the same around time
horizon if horizon was coming out this
year we would know a release date they
don't even i don't think they have a a
window there's not even a window for god
of war it's literally just 2022.
and you know why they're doing that so
they can delay to 2023.
track record when horizon was on point
i'll give you that you you you would
have one of the few this no king we
haven't even seen game play from god of
war really just like snippets i mean
we'll see what happens but
what they're going to do is this year
they're going to do that indeed thing
with god of war
in the year gameplay
like the next day to play or whatever
whatever big thing they do before e3
time yeah and there is no talk of of a
god of war release date you're
absolutely right it's not coming out
this year but like the very next time
they come up with something a showcase
an event where they go and saw a show in
new games they have to have the release
date if it's going to come out this year
the thing is slo-mo is
sony don't really release stuff that
they own
in the holiday section i mean i guess
god of war could be an exception but i
don't feel like they have a wireless
demon souls remake but that was really
that that's different because that's
release title console games that that
has a specific person a specific reason
why that game had to be out that year
that time because they wanted to release
it alongside a console you can't really
take those standards and apply it to
everything
that's true although i i still think
that like they could come out like hey
in april and say god the war releasing
in september or august and that would be
when have they ever been known to do
that though
but that doesn't mean that that doesn't
exclude it from ever happening right
they're not the second half of the year
people all right king you're up because
we gotta move on with it
yeah um no no
is it tied over
it's uh you throw the title towel in
i've seen dudes dominating in a fight
until the last round and getting knocked
the hell out shout out to meldrick
taylor um
12 seconds left so um at no point in
time i'm going to wave the title in no
no march
i i don't i don't care
because like like uh like nick said
we don't know what's going on at the end
of the year we don't know what type of
[ __ ] starfield might come out in that
shape that that that evander holy feels
real deal
and push his wig back and peel his cap
back so
you don't never
starfield could come and take the crown
but all i'm saying you better be that's
right elder ring has that quality work
starfield better show up right you
better be right little to no issues
no no it don't need to show up with
little to no issues it just need to show
up and be what everybody expected if it
comes in
and see because we ain't gonna sit here
and act like this game ain't show up
with issues
all right this disney yeah hustle must
have brought up a point
dropped in march at one game of the year
yeah this this this game right here
shows up with a bunch of warts and a
bunch of issues but dudes is like yo
this is it and
yeah so let's say
uh a star feels shows up
but it's that visual showcase see
the problem with this game here yeah
it's tied to last gen
starfield is not tied to last year's
good point that's a good point
star field is current gin so we don't
know what's going on in there and what
what if it blows the doors off you
visually audibly and everything so
starfield might come and shack the
situation and dudes be like elden who
and only and like like nick said your
five thousand hour dudes is gonna be in
there like no man i'm gonna vote for my
guy
don't matter unless unless god of war or
zelda come out this year star feels the
only game i could see like getting in
the ring without other games it's other
games that can capture the imagination
and heart of people it's it's other
games this ain't the end-all be-all but
it's a great story like what i'm still
waiting for
announced the title go ahead i'm not a
prisoner of the moment i'm not a
zeitgeist dude i try to stay the hell
out of there because again you start
putting on blinders and you start not
looking at what the rest of the year may
lead into to make the rest of the year
may lead into something incredible and
amazing we don't know what might land on
our doorstep you know so
again
is it a great start to the year
yeah for sure
is this one of the best bright spots did
it start to live up to all the
expectations hell yeah
is it game of the year
could be
[Laughter]
but is it
i'm not calling the fight
[Laughter]
fair enough i'll leave it there that was
that was great um yeah i don't have much
to add i didn't play it so i don't have
much ass i'm i'm literally going off of
all the feedback from all the great
players and non-players and souls fans
and non-souls fans i might shout out to
say this to you my share partner so you
know what to do but um
anyway because you know that's they had
me it is what it is but um now it's cool
to see it one thing i am happy is i'm
happy at the success of it you know what
i'm saying because something that kind
of started off i want to say
i don't know if i'm wrong for saying it
the start off kind of niche as a series
and then kind of just grow into this
thing and then yeah hardcore community
and i love the streaming community
aspect of it and people wanting us to
stream on youtube people forget i've
actually been using them a bit
i love it this has nothing to do with
y'all shout out i've actually been to
the elder ring for for putting the elder
ring on top of
i've actually been uh been bored
and looking uh trying to score some easy
souls
so i've been going in and helping people
on lfg fight bosses oh that's what's up
awesome look man uh attic i'm gonna need
some help with a little bit of switch as
we go move on cause these laughs look
like i ain't gotta stream it
[Laughter]
yo just like i said they gon forget like
they gonna forget about elder rig at the
end of the year yo
you
are
messy
all right it only took a couple of hours
i started off strong let me get these
super chats for where i got shout out to
my homegirl k johnson 5 super chat
studying for work and listening at the
same time not as active in the chat
today but still loving the show hit that
like button five just want to make sure
i don't miss donna donna taco on file
super chat took a nice yeah i got
remember we did it we took a nice nap
[ __ ] and we played last lap just wanna
make sure we don't miss because solvers
are here you know how like they get you
know what i'm saying oh mr irish man
appreciate the therapeutic break this
podcast has given me from elder ring
millennia blade of mckellar has been
tanning my damn hide for over 12 hours
i'm assuming that's some boss
yeah can't wait for casey up you got
that then you got donna taco two hours
with chad breath of the wild two
smacking star filled in another ring
okay outside
that's cool that's a possibility too
yeah rain and blade i hate souls games
but i'm loving eldering shout out to the
two pounds super chat again another two
pound super chat i wish i was playing
with addict and smoove rate and blade no
doubt hollywood i've been told by so
many people i've sold copies of that no
no bro you are a fantastic streamer
you can do you can do three uh uh three
player uh yeah oh
so we all get our social security cards
is the way they do the invite system
whack it is but it's not hard oh no
i wouldn't go as far
i wouldn't go i wouldn't go as far and
say it's something like like nintendo
because
they want like a long set code you can
make the code anything you want it
doesn't how many did it like long
there is no cross play though so oh
you have to kind of lock it down
we were going to play this
the playstation the playstation 4 is the
best
anyway moving on the worst game this
might be the worst game to play on pc
because because like the cheating fiasco
going on over there i can't imagine hack
builds coming in to just i can't imagine
playing with the playstation 4 dudes and
they're moving better than me
moving on
hollywood
holly rules bought us a chat a little
late to the party but love listening to
about the cox
can playstation 4 playstation 5 cross
play
you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous and this is why we get
lumped into the foolishness these are
the thoughts of king david
[Music]
just to clarify these are low-key the
thoughts of attitude
oh see you i try to save you absolutely
no no let me know let me answer the
question because i'm bringing it like
it's not a problem okay thank you so
much thank you for the clarity s4 and
ps5 players can can play together they
just you know they just can't be in the
same biome
time anyway hollywood rules
playing the powerpoint once playing the
game
a little late to the party but love
listening to my video game brothers uh
the other great iop sunday keep it up
boys thank you salute hollywood rules
again follow some chat batman had
everything soft set with the graphic
novels and the heavy influence of seven
and the article sevens and the arkham
games loved it
okay hargees should need to hold me ten
hours leave a chat for game of the year
you have to look at who votes they may
not like souls games highest rated game
of last year forza wasn't even
considered games like breath of the wild
2 ragnarok or star field may win instead
okay he's on the next train okay
don otaku y'all tripping
kirby got game of the year all over
these games
oh man god i'm talking about my dollar
super draft from jd gamer good afternoon
lords i haven't
started eldon ring yet but i will be
skidding to it tomorrow all right so
look we're going to move on speedball
into this next one halo infinite as you
want to set it up or you got it yeah you
can set it up all right cool a lot of
stuff going on man so let's start off
with my homie chloe brill
from on twitter he basically talked
about um finally some announcements some
news hillary for the two season two lone
wolves coming in may new arena map
catalyst and um what you call big team
battle map breaker new modes last
spartan standing land grab updated king
of the hill returns four player co-op
during coming during season two forge on
track now for season three
and then um they said he got some other
notes as far because it's a big block
for um 343 the next on season one event
tactical op starts next week including
variants of the tactical slayer mode and
new mark four five six seven core uh
focus rewards to earn marketing
influence season two will start in april
forge is already in private flighting
public flights come later this year and
then they made a final statement just
kind of um from the studio saying that
they have a priority zero as far as team
health getting themselves into a
sustainable development rhythm instead
of priority zero this is sometimes i'd
say it's controversial some people had
some issues means that sometimes we need
to move slower so that we can move
faster later frankly these last few
months have been slower than we expected
and we sincerely thank you for your
patience as we stay true to the
priorities so
i'm gonna give it to you because i think
i know why you wanted to set it off and
i know that you know on the steam front
the numbers were kind of dropping and
there was a lot of concern you know of
what's going on with haylift but i'm not
gonna influence your thoughts what what
was your whole thought process behind
bringing this topic to the round table
i feel like
we've gotten to that point where
microsoft really should have delayed
this game
[Music]
it's like look like
we've always said that you know
i understand why they didn't delay it
but at the same time i do feel like
they push this game out
for good publicity but maybe it just
sacrificed the halo brand doing it
uh you know
all i know is when they come back they
better come back hard yeah because right
now it's not looking so hard for them
well let me ask you this before i pass
it up
what is your main frustration with the
way things have been handled
you know
from three four three since launch time
probably the way that they're trying to
take a season and act like it's multiple
like an event for a season and trying to
act like it's different events when it's
the same event brought back multiple
times just like fractions
that's equivalent to like
season of the lost
being brought back like two or three
times a year and they act like it's
different events but it's really the
same event
it's just they're acting like it's
different events like it's like they're
capping you from getting like let's say
in the first like a month you can only
get to level 20 in the season rank and
then you have to come back to get the
rest of the 20. and then and then again
in another month you have to come back
and get another 20.
that's a good announcer it's like
literally capping the seasonal rank
progress that you could only get to like
level 30 about oh yeah i said you're
going
to like that that is so frustrating that
you see all this nice stuff and they
didn't really go into detail about that
when they first started doing this stuff
it's like look like
i don't think halo's dead yet right but
it's definitely on life support and i
feel like 343 could turn it around but
it's just like when i read statements
like this
i don't think it's happening anytime
soon yeah and the steam numbers were
definitely a bit alarming to me just to
see the the drop off was it from like
was it it was pretty substantial from
300k to now barely
10k yeah let me get you in slowing out
because i know you had a lot to say on
what i've been following
let me let me start off by saying by
talking about how many hours i have in
this game
so for people who may not understand
where you came from i have 82 hours and
44 minutes into this game i have like 3
50 and 531
matches like that i just checked halo
tracker to double check that i say that
before i start to talk about how
i said everything that addict just said
is things that i
saw happening before it happened like
i'm not trying to say i'm i got like i'm
i'm nostradamus over here like king
david right 96 but like every now and
then every now and then like i get an
epiphany and i'm like oh man i can like
i see the vision here of the disaster is
about to happen delay the game right and
people like no don't delay the game and
i'm gonna tell you why they wanted a
lady game and and and i know i know why
king's saying that's right because
people wanted to be like look what we
got right now and oh no information guys
look what you don't have right now
that's not my reason
okay all right
i think there was a lot of people too
for uh
slo-mo that
was just like they just wanted to play
the game at that point like
in years and years keep delaney keep
playing
are you implying that the desire to play
this game
over
the long term
people were really excited for that
campaign and it's just like regardless
if it's good or bad like i i do they are
people out there clearly they're playing
a console war stuff but me and myself i
said multiple times that should be
delayed but i got to the point where i'm
like i'm not going to let a co-op
stop me from playing this for six months
stop me can't stop won't stop we got it
yeah
we got no co-op
even when they okay first they they
promised co-op right we promised it at
launch yeah
we don't got that co-op right now
we go we're going to have the co-op in
season two three months after launch and
i was like
why are y'all complaining you're gonna
get your co-op in three months right and
i sat there like wait man how many times
has 343 said something and then it
didn't turn out to be what they said it
was going to be why now
would you agree
why now would you believe that
so of course
they extended season one now season one
is six months right
come on now like that's way too long you
didn't have you didn't did you add extra
content for season one no that's why
that's why everybody left now
at the beginning of season two we're
supposed to be getting co-op is there
co-op nope
oh people get this at some point in
season two and people believe that why
would you believe look how many times
does he have to keep lying to you
you realize
he ain't work his word ain't working
three four three t
oh okay so okay i just i thought you was
going weird with it no no no no
i thought you would go weird i know
where you thought this was going to
continue
the defense team i know the defense team
was coming i know i already know you saw
us
are you talking about a specific
nightmare
is showing up at three in the morning
smelling like alcohol and weed
and the phone been off for about four
hours that's why
you try to say that they out there doing
unspeakables oh yes
here like i feel like it should have
been it should have been delayed it
should have been well also you got like
only we get only getting in season two
two more maps that's one for big team
battle one for arena and it's like
yo you forget anywhere near being ready
yeah if you have if you have forge there
and i know they're trying to do
something really big and expansive
before if you have forks there right
you could have had the community
creating maps yeah to help you out yeah
yeah
instead of just relying on you to create
maps i'm kind of wondering about slip
space engine in general because we've
seen but other like um you know shout
out to the homie disney but in his love
for frostbite
we've seen other devs work with uh
troublesome problematic engines and not
being able to get
out yeah yeah but you know it's just
like it's
it looks like it should have been
delayed
and
i i just i i mean i'm not trying to get
take my victory lap or anything because
there's no victory to be taken sir
i think they do that with no knees sir
because this i am very curious to see i
have not talked to him about this you
know we definitely uh reviewed this game
lords of
gaming.net plugs plug
pretty much strong reviews you know for
the most part and um what we pointed out
the issues that we did have but uh i
want to talk to you man it's like now
time the dust is settled
and this uh you know information is
coming out and how are you feeling about
you know the state of the game and then
also the latest update from 343 as far
as the timeline of things
it's disappointing it's what it is um i
really really really enjoyed my time
with the campaign i really had a great
time with the campaign overall the
campaign was fantastic and like the
multiplayer it's crisp it's clean it ran
great
no technical issues all that in
comparison to my experiences with like
battlefield 2042 and limited experiences
with call of duty vanguard it was one of
the most polished multiplayer games that
came out over the holidays
but
but i understand we're you know we're in
pandemic settings the health of the
team's important and everything else
but 343 seems to really be using that as
a crutch to just simply not deliver on
content you can't
keep one season for six months and
then drop such a light season two in
terms of content like if you're if if
you're gonna wait like if you're gonna
wait that long on the first season that
season two has to be impeccable it has
to answer at least at least half of the
questions people have
and it's like oh there's more cosmetics
here's two more maps and uh we'll talk
about co-op eventually and it's like
hey like i understand if you're having
issues with co-op just be transparent
with it don't keep giving it a timeline
and just like you know carry it on the
stick just keep extending the stick
um for the fans because it's it's
disappointing and it just it kind of
just shows how
i want to work this carefully how
improperly
run 343 appears to be externally then
they've done very little to quell any
rumors that they are run properly
because they can't seem to deliver on
their own timetables and i think that's
one of the biggest problems that these
big multiplayer games have such as
battlefield stop promising stuff and sit
down and when you can deliver it talk
about it don't talk about what you want
to do how like let's look back up let's
look back on anthem how many blog posts
did bioware point out going oh we've got
all these big plans cataclysms coming
yeah yeah all this and then there was
cataclysm
yo
it didn't show up
you stupid continue
i know that that's big facts like anthem
had a road map and delivered on zero
percent of it
yeah
there it goes for the road map
continue nick fisher boys
yeah it's it's just really disappointing
because as someone who really enjoyed
the campaign i was like you know
maybe yeah maybe 343 gets it
yeah
but they they just don't really seem to
and i i honestly don't know what the fix
is because
even if they deliver on all this content
that they said they were going to
deliver on they're not going to deliver
it anywhere close to the timeline they
said it was so even once that content
comes out there people are still going
to be disappointed
it's like it's like if you're it's like
if your your wife remembers your
birthday six days later yeah it's nice
she remembered but she's how did she
remember it though
there we go that's the thing
here we go
i mean
i don't care that y'all didn't get what
y'all wanted what you mean you don't
care
i don't care cause i got what i wanted
which is i got my campaign and it was
dope and it was fire and i got a
grappling hook and i was sliding all
over the place i had a great time and i
went into the multiplayer i don't care
that y'all got forged yeah no kidding
just general half co-op and i told you
that before oh that's what they don't
care so at the at the same time
at some point in time you know what it
is
is this internet right yeah i can't love
it
oh it's the incident now oh let me hear
this you can't you can't love it and
hate it you can't i love the way the
internet has delivered stuff to me at a
touch of a button this has directly
contributed to broken games so
this is the world of broken games
shipping to you half empty half full
sometimes they can fulfill their
promises sometimes they can't but at
some point in time guess what cyber
cyberpunk 2077 showed me
that game been out
it took a year some change for them to
give you the patch right and you know
what they said so what
you got the patch now now shut up and
play the game now it's full and their
reputation has been damaged irreparably
it got tarnished it got banged up
they got whatever but think about it
this way and pull from the playstation
stuff oh yeah well
they don't give back money that's the
only reason
they really ever have that membership
they was up forget that membership like
listen if they
they were on that road to giving the
all-you-can-do
pass for everything you do
and they and they messed up on that and
now their next game might not sell like
that i don't know some people might wait
to see the performance of the game no
i don't think look i don't think it is
speculation because i there are going to
be a lot of people that got burnt burnt
from from cyberpunk that's going to wait
for those performance sales and there's
a dude right now that purchased the 26
version of the computer game right now
that don't care what you just said and
there is only 60 of them guys
shout out to me for being the 60 of god
so so just to close your mind
i just want to clarify king you you're
talking about
so there's people that's willing to wait
for sell and buy the game for half price
okay then they could do that that's fine
like right is it my fault that y'all
fools rushed in is it my fault that
y'all don't listen y'all didn't get him
oh the game didn't
what i will give you with halo infinite
is they delivered exactly what they
advertised you know what this is halo
infinite here's your single player
here's your multiplayer that's what they
advertise they said no co-op anything
else fine they didn't lie to you about
what was in the game cyberpunk goddamn
lied to you
rigged the review process
we'll talk about some rigging review
process later in the next segment but
again i hear you go ahead sir go for it
oh god i haven't oh my grandchildren
it's reasonable i feel the way you just
brought it away i already see that he
gave he gave his preview bars about
where he at with that
go for it go go
i can't live [ __ ]
don't be getting it
all that money for cyberpunk and you
know what uh
y'all didn't get your refund back from
microsoft and if you was too slow at the
sony store you wasn't getting it back
anyway
so that's the only reason why don't act
like oh it was a quality controls issue
and we decided to pull it because we
didn't like the quality you know you
didn't like people who asked for their
money
from the show so these dudes don't get
that because they don't give back money
that's the real issue
they don't care about the quality they
put out a lot of garbage games all right
you don't care about the quality the
minute you call back and you say yo let
me get my money back for s y and z they
bang your account
okay you took it to there we're just
gonna get you up out of here entirely
it's like you're being it's like you're
being punished for bringing up bad
things
see and this is going to be a motif
going forward they want you silence so
don't so please don't ever bring up the
quality fact they had a quality control
issue playstation is so above of quality
not at all they don't give back money so
let's talk about the broken gain that
was sold to you broken game was sold to
you the internet fixed it over a period
of time with patches and stuff like that
and finally right now you got a complete
game at some point in time this halo is
going to be the complete game that
somebody want listen
you you want forge for you forge dudes
that's out there that's been a part of
this series listen when it happens it'll
be good for you and you know what you're
gonna scream that day that it hits four
just here
yeah i can't wait till 2024. right
you're right
everybody is going to come
how people leave your game is super
important when people are always going
to put your game down on ongoing live
service game down to go play something
else how they put your game down is
really important to how they whether
they determine whether they decide to
come back or not
for example if they say i am
dissatisfied because you said you was
going to have xyz here
you don't have that stuff for example
that's not what i'm saying look look a
great example of this is no man scott no
man sky did not live up the expectations
that launched yes now the game is great
now yeah the game is great now that is
kind of an example of gamers that stayed
on their squares
how many people how many people actually
came back to see the play wheels we
won't never notice
like you're sitting there trying to get
metrics
knows
you know what they also know nowhere
near as many people came back to that
game and the people that i would play to
that launch and was like y'all allowed
to be disappointed i mean i i don't know
about that because
the game is doing very well that's what
i'm trying to say like like if anything
i would say more people are there right
now than they were there's no square to
stand on though look look it's becoming
it's becoming increasingly more clear
that all you guys are destiny fans
because you guys don't have any
standards for what i didn't say anything
don't love me don't load me into nothing
that is him that is that man talking
i didn't get my balls
yeah when y'all attack please attack me
yeah singly like because i attack people
straight up yeah so it's it's it's
my philosophy isn't cogs philosophy is
it addicts philosophy i appreciate other
people's philosophy i don't care what
anybody thought when halo release it
released i don't care it can't and dude
it's like oh we co-op it's not me it's
not halo master chief in the chief x
it's just me right here playing this
game so i really
talked to you about it yo did you get
past this part that's cool the singular
story stuff i'm having fun doing this
right here when when the co-op part do
come out yeah i might play with somebody
in co-op but i've really dissected the
whole thought process of it and i said
you know what i've done most of this
halo stuff by myself and anytime i did
do multiplayer i've done multiplayer in
the same fashion that i've done it so
there's at least two things that i've
done in the same way that i've done it
right now that talks to me now when the
forge dude gets forged i'm telling you
right now if they say if they launch
forge in the next two months
forge comes out all that that back
talking about it was talking
yeah but listen all the forge dude back
talking that he's doing today he's gonna
cross right across the street from
inside forge and all that talk is and if
they prom and if they deliver how ford's
supposed to be oh yo you know that in
the forge right now i can make the steps
and everything i'd have made a map you
could come check out my map because you
know i'm the number one forge dude so
again
it doesn't matter there's no square to
stand on because once they give you what
you what you're looking for you'll be
right back there and slow-mo if those
people don't come back good on them
because you know what they're doing
playing something else right because
something else occupied their time right
but if they really cared about the stuff
that they're talking about they care
about their champion so much when it
does come out there's no way in hell you
can sit there and talk about i'm not
going to eat that cheesecake because it
didn't have cherries on top and they put
cherries on top of the cheesecake you
eating the cheesecake
that's my point the longer they wait to
actually come out with content that
people want the more people are going to
be like i got other stuff to play and
then sometimes they never come back and
they're not going to come back in a live
service game which demands engagement
and you know what this is this is how
i'm i'm not a microsoft shill and i'm
i'm i'm a gamer this is this is how i'm
not a microsoft shell and i'm a gamer if
they don't come back then you messed up
the next time you do better okay that's
it awesome fair enough addict got his
head raised
i know you wanted to delete
like you trying to say two three months
fam they talking like six to nine months
for a stroll
you can come out tomorrow i'm not
playing it
here's the thing though here's the thing
halo can be saved when forge comes out
but it can't just be forged they need
something to bring the masses back
like some giant story expansion or
something
and they bundle that with yes uh with
forge and it can't just be that too that
they need to have like the classics map
pack that comes with that too where you
have forge you have a story expansion
and you got like 10 of the old maps all
bundled together would you come back
i i i would come back then i'm i i love
you i'm going to come back for food
i never if you put rubies inside the
bucket they all come back but here's the
thing i never said i was never going to
come back
i've always look how i look how i treat
destiny destiny is definitely the the
definition of a mistress i only go
around there every couple months like
but
i'm sorry
i'll show up at the last couple weeks
and do everything i need in destiny and
move on it's just like that's how it
came to be halo
i kind of fell off on it because a lot
of the gamers that i enjoy is not on
there i never expected them to be on
there like full time because people look
where's grifball cripple's never been
there full time like never understood
that mindset for the most part grifball
has always been a seasonal thing yeah
and it's just like look like they messed
up and
they
i get it
i did the unlocking of the armors and
stuff like that was trash and the way
that i was grinding i was grinding to
kill myself to do that so i just left it
alone yeah look let me jump in um
this is funny oh my thing is this you
know i've been on i think me and maggie
talk about it like i have definitely
been on team delayed from the jump i've
always been on that and i didn't
understand
you know this mindset that it had to
drop like especially when forza was
outside and i was just like foster
horizon is outside is is doing
phenomenal so i didn't understand and i
get it you know it was hella high water
this thing is coming right all right
cool and you you banked on the early
success but my point is kind of like
what attic said which is like i just
hope as a result you don't
risk the long-term health of this game
now that king is right too
that yeah you know when the content drop
when it does come dudes that's talking
gonna come back and play for the most
part but this is what i said and and and
slow someone you'd appreciate it
when you go live service
to me i said the key with them is going
to be the adaptability and the
flexibility of the live team that's
doing the day-to-day right because if if
you don't if that team is not delivering
content and meeting deliverables destiny
went through periods like this where
it's like yo
your base will leave and they will be in
whatever's the new hotness and the funny
thing is
bungie works on two forms of content
uh 343 to my knowledge is only working
on the multiplayer like they don't
really work on campaign
i would say they have a team working on
something like the next expansion again
the live team is going to be things so
we already seeing some signs now of
deliverables now not being met after
being promised right
that is gonna rub people wrong wrong way
all i say is this
to the co-op thing that's the one that
got me to my soul nick i know me and you
talked about that that's like a
tradition for you same thing for me i
was not feeling no co-op at launch at
all like i'm still on that square they
should have delayed it but my thing is
this though like
at this point six
months it's loose
like
my thing is it comes out at that point
and this is where i'm 100 without it
who gonna care at that point like unless
you packaging it
with new story content
at the same time
you dropping a campaign to everybody
that ran through
a zillion times is not gonna have any
real impact so to me what they need to
do if possible
package it with new content
and the new season with new pvp maps for
the forged in and you're gonna have to
drop it as a beefy thing because i feel
like what the mistake that cyberpunk did
is like yeah they did the patch but it's
like again so many people have already
abandoned the game like you've already
killed the base and i'm not gonna the
steam numbers are alarming
i i don't know about like 300 out of 10k
like that is alarm and that is like what
is going on like pc gamers are not
playing and the sad thing about it is
that that's damn near almost battlefield
the sad thing about it is the game is
amazing like it is the most fun
multiplayer i've ever played the solo
single game player is solid it is just
like yo live team you know again i'm not
trying to be disrespectful i know people
have lives i know there's things going
on i'm not saying it's not a pandemic
it's just the fact that the fortnite
formula is the best formula and they
don't emulate that i don't care you
gotta have content you gotta have
content yeah accessible content i can i
can't do all the crap i have to do to
get the samurai gear yeah
that's all i'm saying
to do it and i can't unlock certain
things so i think they have to work on
that part but they have to get a regular
cadence for what they do yeah
exactly and they're not living up listen
i hear the frustrations of everybody and
stuff like that and when i joke around
and talk about i really don't care
honestly i really don't care
the bottom line to it is
somebody else out there does care yeah
so
how many rubies do they need to put in
the bowl for you for you to come back
and say oh because all i keep hearing is
if they add some extra story content
then that's a boon of benefit for me
because then i come back to it as well
yeah so that's all
how they release those skins and stuff
yeah
it's cool that's what i'm saying look
you know i'm pulling for them i i hope
they they they adapt and this new
story campaign stuff and all that stuff
gets out of there because the game is
amazing they just need to support you
can't give me samurai week three you
know what i'm saying in the giant and
it's the same old map and they're
terrible
anyway that's it i got it but look i
mean
that's playstation stuff and we got to
get away from telling people our our
resume yeah yo uh uh i put in uh i got a
platinum-ness i i don't care but he
talked about i don't know but i
understand there was slo-mo coming from
talking about no i understand what he
says because he's been on the front line
defending
so much it has become commonplace to
yell out credentials when you walk in
the door
we already know your credentials
right so the credentials when you're
walking i've seen it
i'm i i've planned them i have 400
platinums i don't care like i've played
the same game that you played maybe i
didn't play it to the same extent that
you've played it so that doesn't give it
an entire thing but at the same time we
know how much work you put in that's
what i'm saying like so that's just fact
checking for other people that want to
look and pull up later on on slow mo uh
let them go check your resume if they if
they care so much about your resume let
them go check your resume and let them
just sit there and be quiet with your
resume you are solidified
they don't have let them go find out
yeah i mean i get where y'all going i
mean look that's another subject but i
do agree with slow in the sense that
like i said we just want what's best for
the game and that would have been a
little bit okay with it late but again i
just hope that they're able to recover
and do what they need to do because
people like the game but we've got to
move on i'm going to switch at the end
because i don't want to go too long with
the florida show but um
yeah this will be quick this one um is
kings traffic
um yeah so i don't know how king wants
to approach this but gran turismo
has released and um
you know again for the most part what
does it say like almost like an
88-minute critic i didn't even get a
chance to check that because i'm playing
destiny for 12 hours so apologies for my
lack of having that info available but
um yeah like it's been it's been for the
most part well received um release date
seems to be making this release date you
know which uh there might be some knees
online there but you know i will say
that there is some conscious money okay
respect um there is some controversies
in the sense of i believe micro
transaction model and then also um
there i guess people are pulling up that
from a detailed standpoint that the
backgrounds
people or something or not as detailed
or whatever so king
the floor is yours you brought this to
the table
what are you doing well i i i i want to
say
that i didn't expect the game to um
release
yes and um
i thought it was missed this day by a
couple of days but it did and it hit
it came out and and they did it and i
know why they did it now
they weren't too sure about for
horizon
so if i if i knew the internals on it
because if they were really sure on
horizon i think this game would have
been pushed back a little bit to give
horizon some breathing space but right
now these two games actually together
make a good collaboration
all right so
you have this game and what they did was
and this is the sly sneaky part about
their review process because the review
process needs to be uh re-reviewed
right because they had the micro
transactions and all that stuff locked
off for those people that did get a
chance to review it and if you didn't
give sony a favorable review on certain
things you were kind of locked out of
that situation right so
you get this game and you don't get to
know that the moment the dick game does
go live and the micro transactions
then goes live right
you have a game that before if you was
playing uh gran turismo motorsport uh
what was it um the the sport game like
you just bought it
you can buy the joints for like five
dollars like you know in the currency
that has scaled up to inflation levels
of like 40 bucks
20 to 40 bucks
on now for free to play model
that works
but we're talking about a 70 game
that you're paying for
and then the micro transactions inside
said game is quadruple to triple
what the previous game was
the point of contention is a lot of
people talking about it the problem with
that is
is that that's absolute false
advertisement right especially when it
comes to the review process because the
reviewers weren't able and privy to have
that information before the reviews go
live
also there's a point of contention with
the ray tracing
the ray tracing is only available in
photo mode
um
you saw when nobody's talking about the
downgrading graphics
nobody's ever everybody's walking past
the downgrading graphics if you see the
trailer from the e3 trailer all that
beautiful ray tracing and it's the
moving and the cars is hitting the
corners and it's dipping in his slide
and then when you see the actual game it
looks like the same boring gran turismo
the same and then they don't tell you
that the cars you're getting you're not
getting two thousand and
the earliest you're getting is 2017 and
2012 to 2017 and you got to be happy
with those versions of that car
is that funny what is this a vintage
what are we what do we have here what
are they giving you got 400 old cars
like yo you don't have 400 new cars and
you have variations of old cars you got
variations of a skyline like you who's
happy to have a 2013 skyline
2013 skyline and rip these streets
so pretty much what you're trying to old
stuff
pretty much for sure implying king is we
didn't get gran turismo in 2022 we got
gran turismo in 2017. thank you
that's the that's the game that they
made and that's where they cut it off at
that's
they've been making it for how many
years and they stopped at 2017. there's
this there's no cause past 2017 in the
game
so that means that means my truck won't
be in the game
yo
but i'm driving my truck so i can't
drive my truck in the game i can't i
can't hop in this
where am i suburban
kid with you
your cog
your range ain't in there
like you two how many times do you go
get a racing game and you go actually go
get your car yeah you understand like
you yeah this is me i'm i'm just gonna
buy that because that's what i do in
real life you don't say it you can't go
get the 2021 stingray from corvette why
you can only get the 2017.
dude's [ __ ] with a 3.5 he said
yo
why he got a 88 why is it not 2017 why
isn't he don't have a 17 why is it the
score 17. this is see where attic is at
he's in the past and that's exactly
where gran turismo is supposed to be
with their old antiquated tear your
pockets up
the fact that they held reviewers in
this manner hostage and then spring
attack them later on and then they don't
tell you in on the packaging
cars are limited to
the year 2017.
you can't even remind me of the
imaginary player jay-z yo dawg what's
the difference between the 4.0 and the
four-voice
30 grand
beat it
i go
i can't say the lyrics with
let's open it up man this
is a premium premium boss oh let's get
slow-mo first i don't know if he's been
following this whole situation i have
not this is all news to me
they got
is it a texture pack dlc
or something like what this i don't know
what's going on i've alerted about it
did you see that did you see the twitter
video where the car was flipping and it
looked crazy
it looked like a box car like it was
like it was recorded in someone's garage
likes
i mean wow like look i i just like i'm
not into the uh like racing simulation
games like the most i do i'm not a big
racer guy at all but like the arcade
racer like forza horizon i'll jump on
that for a few weeks enjoy my time with
it really have fun but like uh forza
motorsport uh gt
um
you want me to be tuning cars like that
like that like a couple of hours just
trying to get the car just right i'm
good
i'll do something else but like yeah
i've been i've been kind of hearing some
things i did i did hear that they tried
to pull the call of duty activision
where like you you add in micro
transactions after the reviews are after
the game
so i was just like yeah that's kind of
that that's that's kind of shady there
like you can't be doing stuff like that
expect people not that not
to pull it up for you
black and white
anyway
um
what's your thought process on all of
the gt7 stuff
look uh
i've got my own opinions about 70 games
i'm canadian so when you say 70 games i
say dollar games right you say 40 cars
they're 50 cars um
but my bit my biggest problem is
is you know part of the reason that so
many people were accepting of these 70
games was the fact that we would you
know maybe they won't put these glaring
micro transactions in the game and the
feedback i've drawn i am not a gran
turismo guy i am not going to pretend
i'm some racing sim guy i got like 2 000
wheel or anything like that i play
arcade racers that's it i ain't gonna
cap like i know what i'm talking about
but the general consensus is is that the
e-commerce of the microtransactions in
gran turismo 7 kind of suck and not in
terms of how you earn currency there's
ways to earn currency everyone's kind of
fine with so far what they played the
how you earn your currency everything
seems to be fair but they said there is
a major disparity between how much
currency you're getting for how much
money you're paying
so
what they're doing and this is something
that call of duty figured out eons ago
is that you get your standard players
who will play the game to unlock their
stuff whatever they don't care but then
there's whales that go i don't want to
earn this stuff i'll pay whatever i've
got to to get the cars i want right and
they're specifically gouging those
people for more money
whether that's right wrong or
indifferent
that's up to people to determine and i
will leave that argument up to people
that are playing this game and if they
have a problem with that they should
voice their opinions with it but i got
you slow
but
my biggest one and this comes from
someone who reviews games pre-embargo i
wish game developers and publishers
would stop sneaking stuff in on launch
that we can't review in the process
because then we're not giving honest
reviews there's nothing worse as a
reviewer is writing your review putting
your review out and then somebody gets a
copy of that game in their hand and
they're like oh my god how did you miss
this right right right
and then you're like well it wasn't
there
but i was reviewing the game and they're
like oh bs
the thing is at the end of the day
if you're going to give out review
copies it should be the full experience
of what you are selling right within
reason
because if this had been in their day
one and then sliding them in like under
the railing as part of like the day one
patch that's just not cool and you know
if gran turismo guys feel a certain sort
of way about it i 100 understand them if
they don't more power to them no doubt
slo-mo you got your hand up and uh yeah
yeah you know here's here's completely
ignorant about this stuff slow-mo here
question uh
is this a live service game
it
it has to be online well it's got crazy
micro transactions i would assume it is
all right so like usually like that and
maybe it's just me that i don't mind
like if you're going to like charge
obscene amounts of money for individual
things in the game if a game is free
if it's a free game yeah because people
gotta make money so it's definitely not
free it's definitely not right
that's just it this isn't a free game
but yet you're still charging macro
transactions like this like now you
can't you can't have your hands in both
and you have both hands
in like that you gotta choose to charge
this amount of money and then not charge
people like that or maybe you have a few
things here and there but the prices are
much lower since they already paid that
premium price to get in then
they paid the payment a premium part
price to get into the club right you
shouldn't be charging them crazy money
once they're already in there but then
there's the other side of the dollars to
use the bathroom exactly right now like
if it's free then i i get it you need to
make money somehow if they really care
once
they play the game for free and they
really love it they sure charge them
whatever you know but like to do both i
think that's really messed up well what
their argument is is they're saying that
through natural gameplay you'll you will
get credits in this game this currency
and then that eventually just by
long-term play you'll supposed to get
david to cut the car the cars you want
that's also a mobile game mobile game
like thing where they give you they do
give you a
a trickling of uh
money to make that of ways to generate
in-game revenue to get what you want but
the process is so slow right it's so
frustrating that people just spend the
money anyway so because progress is
locked behind badges badges is locked
behind these you know those licenses
that you get that you have to go through
every course so you have to use this car
you have to go progression progression
is mad slow
in this type of game in this game in
general because you have to go through
board through board with a certain car
to do this to get to the next level to
end the trickle down is so low that it
forces like uh
nick said the whales in order to go out
and purchase to to advance right so it's
like pay to play so basically in the
last thurismo game you could just
purchase cars directly at a set price
yeah now they're saying that players can
only get the cars of the game by these
in-game currency credits um which range
from um like i said about three dollars
of four hundred thousand dollar credit
or twenty dollars for two million dollar
credits and then
basically what they were saying is that
um some cars in sport
could cost almost forty dollars you know
what i'm saying so that so basically
they're saying that it's meant to
encourage some their credit cards are
trying to get players to try to grind
for their cards and then in-game credits
but the the basic point is you got to
get that that all that currency you know
what i'm saying to be able to do what
you want so yeah it means it's
interesting i'll i'm jumping before
attic actually he's in black and white
because he's the car and throws
enthusiasts so let's get his thoughts
first
get the car enthusiastic
i mean when it comes to the the micro
transactions
i'm okay with charging people shortcuts
that don't want to do stuff i'm not okay
with inflating a game and trying to and
trying to encourage you to do it a big
example is assassin's creed i don't like
that they inflate the experience and
then ex and then yo we got this this
time saver they literally call it time
saver this time saver 10 double xp when
in all since that's probably what the
game was originally supposed to have in
terms of experience so they have to
charge you for it yeah not for that now
you know as far as like the review
process that's slimy i think reviewers
should i feel like when stuff like that
happens
the industry shifts
they should speak more vocal about that
like it should be something because i
didn't i didn't feel like no one was
really saying too much like like any of
the big sites like if someone
sneaks a patch and they change a drastic
thing such as putting microtransactions
in a game
you should immediately go back and
revisit that at me because that's what
they they do it on purpose
so they they can kind of get away from
the
the aspect of a review process in
general they're like oh this is the
worst part about our game let's let's
save this for after we give you right
after the game launches we've seen we've
seen publishers and developers do weeks
after a game comes out
uh it is what it is on that you know
the biggest issue i'd have is i can't
play with any
like look man i'm broke i play these
games you drive expensive cars
and and if if my cousin got a more newer
car than that's on this game that's an
issue like
no i mean and that definitely i actually
think that's about issue yeah the whole
i wonder why licensing-wise they
couldn't get new cars but the thing that
um shout out to video games chronicles
they have it and they said so pretty
much the issue is cars that used to be
like five dollars
in the old g because i don't play gt
like that so i'm learning this stuff
right now so they were saying like now
you have to
was it the porsche 919 which could be
bought for three dollars in gran turismo
support can only be bought in gt7 for
three million dollar credits which
equates to spend 40 dollars
yeah you can
you could earn it engage by playing but
you got to earn again okay see i'm okay
with that like look like they've been
doing it for a long time battlefield 3
the old battlefield days they've had
shortcuts to get into like you don't
have to to grind and like you know no
but the old one flying around and stuff
you don't have to grind with certain
packages you can literally do a shortcut
and unlock the entire tree they've been
doing that forever i'm okay with that as
long as they don't inflate the exact
that's what happened
that's what happened they've inflated
the direct
purchase experience so what you would
pay five dollars for three dollars for
this car in the old one you it now costs
three million dollar credits which
equates to at least forty dollars right
now if you want it right now
so that's what so it went from like five
to forty that's what people are saying
apparently it's not an issue because
that that metacritic score kind of high
for all these uh these concerns but is
it
because
see is it high because they didn't have
the information privy to the the the the
release of this i mean they definitely
had the information about the about the
cars right oh yeah the old car stuff
mm-hmm right there and there should have
been concerns like if that i've not
played i'm definitely not going to play
this like there's certain games that
i'll be talking to solve should we
review it you can ask solve i ain't come
to that man one minute for this damn
game no
ain't nothing that gt7 review i'd rather
i'd rather pluck my eyeballs out to play
gran turismo well the problem with me
was
this was one game that i was like
because after seeing atrial i was like
y'all i might have to but the knee get a
business
and then i come to find out that they
don't have no game no cars past 20
days look at the other day people got
issues with this year
don't buy it you know i'm gonna put you
on twitter
tag
i mean obviously do it respectful don't
like go out there talking wild which you
know i ain't your daddy you want to talk
wild you could talk while but i wouldn't
do it it's like look at that like if you
speak about it man yeah make a podcast
about we talking about it man we've been
on here for almost five hours
everybody
it's just like look like as long as
people that's why i was so vocal about
the elderly stuff the stuff i would like
to see a change i don't care if
stacy bob and jane on twitter have an
issue with it i'm just speaking because
i personally want those to change in the
from software formula and you know until
you start speaking about it because i
don't think
vote with your wallet that don't work
there's too many casuals out there that
will buy that game there's just way too
many there's been very few times i've
seen in gaming industry in the industry
since i've been covering it where
there was so many people speaking with
their wallet it actually meant something
and most the time it wasn't even
speaking with your wallet when the game
wasn't even out yet the game wasn't out
so there's no way that you could speak
with your wallet it was the massive
amount of people attacking them on
twitter and social medias that got the
job the job done it wasn't speaking of
your wallet
they care more about that public image
than they care about a game that ain't
even out yet that's all i got about it i
don't play i haven't played gt in so
long like that was when the licenses
used to come out remember when it first
came out yeah and it was probably one of
the most visually impressive games it
was like photorealistic graphics for the
first time i've ever seen we used to
watch those replays and be like yo that
wasn't like real life
yeah so i mean so look at them pull off
a different but at the end of the day
like yeah if if this is the case again i
have not played it but i'm going by what
these reports saying and the inflation
is that crazy
then yeah
i'm good
how do you have an inflation on digital
content it's out of control yeah i don't
know but that's all i got unless anybody
got it i mean you know the cars are
appreciated over time
you can't drive for the day that's the
real free-to-play model you can't drive
in there you got no gas you refilled the
ball automatically yeah yeah it is oh
yeah ideas out hey that's in the next
joint wow
so and i honestly see how fours are
gonna smash it in the face all they
gotta do is offer cars
addicts done it's gonna be super chat's
getting crackers yeah
shout out all right so let me see we got
a trip uh jd gabe i think we read him
good afternoon lords i haven't started
eldering it but i will be getting into
tomorrow
shout out to donald taco 10 super chat
y'all over exaggerating it the base
gameplay is perfect i guess talk about
halo infinite the only thing missing is
content once the content is there the
game will be healthy it's not like
battlefield 2042 where it has no hope of
coming back
like the rubber knob with the five-hour
australian morning lords just speaking
for myself i'm still loving halo almost
capped the season game needs more modes
and weapons though flame followers of a
chat i blame halo sun and multiplayer
launch for the death of halo overall i'm
so glad i never played it and i never
will stop the cat for halo dragon flame
with the very explosive take okay you
know what i'm saying scatter lights
skater lights excuse me five hours of
chat seat these 25 million gamers 3
years after launch halo will be fine
agrees with king
brett bingham 5 super chat good
afternoon lawrence i just bought elder
ring it's my first from software game oh
no what have i done
don
but forza see if these grounded flights
him and age of empires four showing up
with all this content consistently got
343 looking down bad right now so he
gave a counter point in his own point
shinny 10 subject given playstation
played favorites with reviewers
we know reviewers getting codes are
inflating their ratings to keep those
codes coming need to move 5 to 10 points
in ps meta scores to get real scores sad
okay
feeling great he's not lying but oh lord
hear me feeling away about the review
system i make sure no no no it's just
you know certain things spitting his
truth and that's what i got there on the
super chat to get the poll get up all
right listen let's get the final tally
on the shirts to see if i was right
and i don't have to play anything so i
do apologize for all you guys that
thought that was gonna happen it didn't
happen shout out to you guys that
actually love me that didn't have me
force me to have to play elder rings you
need four more four more no we don't we
didn't
yeah i know what to do um anyway
like 10 15 minutes for those four no we
don't
[Music]
make sure that we got that lick in there
just to make sure you know people are
cognizant yeah you have a pole yeah
no you don't i got to eat
[Laughter]
new iop pole with the massive early
financial and critical success of ellen
the ring which game releasing in 2022 do
you think has a shot
at challenging for game of the year hold
on forte with the two dollar super chat
i see you slow-mo representing dp as
well
solutions hey i do what i do bro what's
up man you already know sir though
dave stevenson the building you know
what i'm saying jd game if i was just
super subject change not gonna cap i
need microsoft to get me sequels to blue
dragon lost odyssey salute all right so
back to the poll which game released in
2022 do you think has a shot releasing
for challenging it for game of the year
the choices are a
god of war ragna rock
b
starfield
or c
i don't care stop the fight
game of the year 2022 is already over
eldon king
shout out to all those in the vote go
rock that out it should be up on
logicgamer.net twitter and on the
website itself want to salute again
everybody that pulled up the last word
podcast talking that destiny that he
bought his that thai guy travis go check
them out man salute to my bros for
pulling up talking about that raid again
salute to the assistant editor-in-chief
lawyergaming.net nicholas downey my man
pulling up doing double duty for us a
little bit with solve going so i
appreciate checkman and where can five
people find you what you got going on
uh people can find me on twitter at
nicholas underscore downy and you find
all my written words reviews and whatnot
on lords of gaming.net got a bunch of
stuff playing for this week so uh yeah
stay tuned for that yeah yeah you
already know what's giving it moving and
shaking fantastic editorial teams guys
been killing it for us man love what he
is doing and salute to the whole team
again salute to our scribe of the month
as well daniel amoroso who pulled up
tremendous tremendous stuff in the team
i'm loving the new energy right now i
like the new bloods we got right now a
lot a lot of talent so i'm excited to
see what we got going on for
lawyergaming.net and of course dps one
half
of it oh damn i heard it i heard the
chime all right so my heart gets today
got the preview of t how much is that
addict how many that we need
thank you
all right cool and then
what happened the dps podcast bombay
slow bow backslap chief moderator in ilp
holding it down oh no he bought four so
you have
alright
four more perches does that count yes
that counts
should be in the clutch from three
or the mvp
my man salute at the buzzer cover that
clutch kick without me streaming elder
ring i'll let uh attic and him decide
the terms of the arrangement or how
that's gonna be going down
man
you ain't feeling that but anyway slow
mo what happened
to your slow-mo
[Laughter]
flag with the field flag with the field
but slovo man my brother dps podcast you
know you've been killing it in your
content one of the actually underrated
streamers i actually like when you
stream games especially when it's
something you don't want to play i think
it is the funniest thing ever my man
where can i find people find you what
you got going on sir
hey man first up uh i really enjoy i
always enjoy coming and hanging out with
you guys because it's always a good time
the beta boys thing i mean like
whatever it is i always like i always
got so much love for you guys so it's
just like it's like it's hanging out
with a bunch of friends and just having
a good job brother i love it um you guys
can find me uh name slow mo backslap on
twitter twitch uh twitch ad for my lunch
time with slow-mo i do that probably
weekdays every every lunch time that's
like hey
eat your lunch while you're at work
watch me get bodied in some games or
bite yourself
however they go right and then and then
my my youtube channel is about the same
name as well i like to talk about we got
dps podcast with the homie
gaming forte my co-host so every
thursday night 9 p.m eastern and as well
let's just other videos i'll do i'll
talk about games that i love so you know
come check it out and uh you guys have a
great way have a great weekend i
appreciate you man
[Laughter]
gotta go to the discord so you go to the
royal merch search for the disco
but i'm also checking to the stream hold
on
[Applause]
lord addict where can the five people
find you what you got going on sir
you can find me on twitter lord addict
iop uh you can find me i'll be having a
video out tomorrow i have no clue what
that video is going to be at this moment
but i'll wing it like i wing everything
in life
uh i'm pretty sure
i don't know are are we still doing this
raid an hour better see what's gonna
happen
if we do that i'll probably stream that
on the twitch channel um and uh you know
i forgot something king you could stream
that you could stream straight from the
twitch app on your xbox now yeah i know
that's what i'm gonna do yeah yeah
and i gotta just point out that just
gonna point out
it's called king david iop go follow me
oh my picture's up there and all that i
already made it all right and
so obviously that probably won't be
straightened on the youtube channel
because i don't think you could call
stream like that unless you do there
might be a way to finesse that i don't
know but i appreciate everyone for
coming through uh you know it's like go
follow the iop twitch channel if you
guys want to uh it's it's in the
description
you know the uh the hopefully we'll be
able to finish the raid i don't know and
i will be resuming some of my elden ring
of
nonsense tomorrow no doubt you already
know lord king
we're gonna find people finding what you
got going on sir
first uh my man nicholas
you know i love you
canadian's finest
so uh so as soon as i i definitely want
to go to canada for real because uh
stuff that i want to do up there so when
i go up there i'm definitely going to
give you a heads up because the wife and
i will be going up there and i want you
to show me the finest thing
we will find you the best moose to ride
around
if that's an actual thing that'll be
dope
slow you guys my dude
you like this apparently horizon cells
went down by eighty percent one yeah
i knew it would and it got it got beat
like i told you elder ring put the elden
ring on it pause um
and that's it slow mo my dude i love
when you slow show up please bring your
camera next time oh my god
i do that was coming
[Music]
just stupid my brother uh i hope
everything worked out with the car i
swear you know i was texting him in the
background so i hope everything is fine
it's terrible when somebody uh breaks
into your space
and goes into your space like they they
can do that
and i hope uh you know because we live
in a police state now so i hope the
cameras is out there i hope uh they get
persecuted to the fullest extent of the
law because the violation of that nature
your personal space should not go
unchallenged and should not go
uh like uh uncalled for they definitely
need to get persecuted um i don't
believe in any of that stuff um
my manny bontes showed up
in a minute yo it was what's crazy is
what uh you know i make a joke about it
but hebantus is like i said the the the
soloist the controller you know
to to
hear that he didn't have like a raid
team going in
and then for him to find out that other
dope dudes didn't have a raid team too
it's always the assumption that you know
the the dope girl always has a date
you know and
you know dude always has a date that's
an assumption that we have and let me
tell you something a lot of times it's
because they so dope and they so fly
they they feel other people feel that
they can't approach them yeah or because
or they assume so there's assumptions to
it but it's dope that he put that out
there let y'all know next time you
consider him when it goes to you know oh
i mean let me talk to him first you know
type of thing he should never be the
last one inside the bar that never
should happen ty guy travis my dude i
had a great time with him on halo so for
when he shows up i have a great time
with him he's always infectious fun
hard-working diligent dude i love the
stuff that he does fantastic dude can't
wait to pull him from ign yo um
[Music]
wow
okay if you think i'm joking up there i
know you didn't whatever
we gonna come straight for thai guys um
understand cause y'all get ours right so
we coming for yours
you want to look at us at the farm right
so we're looking at y'all as the farmers
stupid that's the that's the first dude
i'm going for
but i'm this serious um
catch me on twitter king david otw catch
me on twitch king david io king david
iop that's new yeah yeah that's why i've
been streaming it from since you guys
wanted to do that hard geek me you got
to have a conversation because you
didn't have to do that
oh like me
i just followed your twitch channel
because i can't wait to see this drink
yes yes it's going to be absolutely
disgusting but it's going to be fun
because y'all guys are gonna get a
chance to see uh you know me go down
pause um and
and iop everywhere please go to lords of
gaming.net but this fine man is sitting
right here is doing incredible things
always championed him i would he was the
first dude i poached like
yo he was the first dude i've actively
fonded over to get him to
lawsongamer.net he knows it he
understands that i respect him and i
respect his powers so i respect
everybody at loads of gaming.net all the
hard work that they actually do and i'm
gonna tell you man we got the best the
brightest and the finest dad at all
times so please go check out this stuff
because they bust their butts
each and every day and we're gonna put
them through their paces when we go to
packs because we're gonna be doing
videos and sending stuff up to these
dudes that they're gonna have only
only lords of gaming.net will have that
information first i can guarantee that
for a fact because we'll be going on the
floor and getting it and posting it that
same day hitting the ground running
packs will be coming up soon april again
for those who were not aware we got the
uh shirts and all that stuff up there so
if you if you guys are planning i'm
sorry
no no no no no okay yeah for purchasing
oh no doubt yeah for us because at the
end of the day if you guys are gonna be
out there make sure um you holler at us
had those uh packs shirts on i just put
them in there again in the chat
everybody missed it and um yeah we
always take a picture with the lords man
we looking for it you know we're going
to be outside it's been a long time i
believe mom even right now shout out to
dom and them guys they were telling me
the mass mandates in boston actually
left it as well so um yeah come check us
out we'll be out there in the floor and
all of the lords for the first time all
four of us will be
in packs we've been together on fourth
other end but i think in pax would be
our first time all
four
so come check that out and uh yeah as
far as didn't we go to the first box i
don't remember all this
i feel like solve and you kind of
alternate yeah yeah
yeah and then you was dead on dead labs
here and saw wasn't there
i remember that joint so um yeah we get
that and then also on me getting two
chances real quick on the way out um
i think yes i'm checking jd gaming
donald taco you said two dollars i know
you ain't got this pole up without no
breath of the wild too i just need
confirmation that is coming i just i
don't know you know you got hope we need
come you know what i'm saying but i
guess he could say he got a good point
he could say that for i put got a rat
roll right there i can't record the
attic and no one knows yeah but they
sony said it was coming they did say 22
yeah
please let us know early when the king
eldon ring stream is yes yes oh i
definitely would
um we're going to put the links in you
know to follow on twitter so we'll know
probably more than likely wednesdays no
doubt yeah
i know that one man i see you great show
thank you native native with the 7.77
cents exactly all sevens i gotta hear
lord king's take on moonlight trailers
and whatnot in it or does it fight the
fire does it kick rocks also pc
okay well um moonlight you know is one
of my favorites the statue is right up
there uh xm studio statue he did a great
depiction of him he's been one of my
favorite characters going through i love
the actor that they have doing it i love
the fact that they're going to be
approaching his psychosis and uh
how does he uh handle his multiple
personal uh promotional uh personality
disorder situation
um i love the fact that the god conquer
is being visible uh and the fact that
they're making it more of a supernatural
type of thing so that means we might get
werewolf by night uh and we will get
other characters as far as ghost rider
and marvel knights type of situation
i think that stuff it will open up that
uh
other worldly aspects for marvel i'm
super ecstatic for it i can't wait for
it to actually drop no doubt and then
his second part's question i'll actually
lead us for slomo it's a pc master race
question
he says um i need he said he needs let's
go he says i need pc game recon
recommendations for each of y'all i'm
not i'm not the guy so i'm the first
level he says his his limit he said 20
60 y'all he's a 2060 limit though so
don't blow his video card out so what's
the recommendation for a couple games
for him
oh man i mean i don't know what kind of
games division
yo
yo that was a shot
that was cold blooded
that was completely unnecessary
the division two is still harder to run
on on pc hardware than oh wow
[Music]
one guy's facts to another guy's opinion
stop it continue slow stop being messy
continue slow oh he's missing
20 60 recommendations
uh trial law start lost start came out
last month lost ark is very very very
good uh if you like diablo and you'll
love lost ark it's got the same
over-the-top isometric view
very very similar game play but all the
character classes are awesome a lot of
fun no doubt oh show up let me shout out
to uh special nick xbox era man salute
them i see you in the chat brother
congratulations you guys see you got
phil dominance over there salute salute
to the two hopefully i i think i owe you
hopefully i didn't miss it send me a
message on discord bro make sure i owe
you i think i owe you a spot on on on
the show as far as on what you call a
plug so i got to do some homework
hopefully i didn't miss the window often
man this week
you know what i'm saying but um yeah
special next salute man xbox era doing
big things i'm very proud of you i love
what you guys think about always butcher
his name second man caco i always
butcher it i hope i didn't get it right
but anyway y'all know who i'm talking
about salute to y'all y'all doing big
things man i really appreciate it's good
to see you up in here and hopefully we
gotta put a wrench next to his name if
we can you know say that's the homie
right there so take care of that attic
if you can but um yeah and on the way
out i got the
uh
with the clutch with the um classic t
will elden ring take out the king he's
got the pax east 2022 shirt come check
us out man oh there you go nick let me
get you right now hold on hold on
hold on bam yeah got the xbox error
there i got that wrench brother that's
that's good people right there salute
them they want a great show great
website um yeah so my man huggie shiny
he got that joint um he said well elgin
ring take out the king and then he
bought four more pax east iron lord
podcasters
in white my man coming in clutch the
king will have to stream elder rig now
salute to him for being super messy and
getting all king nerve so we love that
when king is upset so go check that out
and again lord if you plan on being at
pax east all of the lords will be there
pull up boston i believe april 20
something we did that wednesday to
saturday let us know i thought it was
the first weeks yeah i think it's i
forget now i gotta get the dates the
first week of april you sure maybe i got
i believe we did during the night i
think i forget but if not if not yeah
better yeah i think i think it's april
the 20th if i'm gonna say but yo check
us out pull up and we're working on big
things there too we got something
hopefully cooking pretty big we'll see
if it goes down but if even if it's not
just come hang out and say what's up but
that's all i got anybody got anything
else before we get out of here long show
these they don't know that's easy
that's all i got everybody enjoy your
sunday we out
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you